شكرا لك جمال وفي تغطيتنا المستمره هذه
في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تواصلوا البحث
عن ناجين تحت الانقاض في اليوم التاسع
لزلزال تركيا وسوريا البدايه من انطاكيا
في ولايتها طاي الجنوبيه تركيا حيث تمكنت
فرق الاسعاف من انقاذ عده اشخاص هذا اليوم
بينهم سيده وشخصان على الاقل من عائله
واحده وعمليه الانقاذ متواصلات كما يظهر
في هذه الصور المباشره
المشهد الاخر في غازي عنتاب لا يختلف
كثيرا عمليات الانقاذ متواصله وكذلك جهود
ايواء المتضررين من الزلزال الارقام في
تصاعد كبير والناجون يواجهون ظروفا يفرضها
واقعهم الجديده
[موسيقى]
وفي اعزاز هذه المره في حلب على الجانب
السوري من مسرح زلزال السادس من فبراير
المدمر ما يجري في المقام الاول هو رفع
الانقاض واخراج جثث الضحايا المحتملين
ثم بعد ذلك من نيويورك تاتينا هذه الصور
المباشره قضيه الزلزال تتفاعل في اروقه
الامم المتحده
يعلن ان فتح معبرين بين تركيا وسوريا
سيكون لمده ثلاثه اشهر فحسب
وفي مواضيعنا في هذه التغطيه المستمره
في اليوم التاسع للزلزال اخراج ناجين من
تحت الانقاض في مناطق عده السلطات التركيه
تعلن تجاوز عدد القتلى 35 الفا ونزوح اكثر
من مليوني شخص
منظمه الصحه العالميه تعتبر الزلزال اسوا
كارثه طبيعيه في اوروبا منذ قرن وتحذر من
تفشي الامراض
وسط انتقادات بسبب تناسب المساعدات مع
الاحتياجات نداء اممي لجمع نحو 400 مليون
دولار لمساعده ضحايا زلزال في سوريا دخول
اول قافله مساعدات دوليه عبر معبر باب
السلامه بعد قرار فتح معبرين اضافيين
بواشنطن تنتقد تاخر فتح المعبرين وتطالب
بفتح المزيد لايصال المساعدات للمتضررين
السوريين
في التداعيات الانسانيه الامم المتحده
تقول ان اكثر من سبعه ملايين طفل تاثروا
بالزلزال في تركيا وسوريا اليونيسيف تخشى
مقتل الاف منهم وتحذر مما اعتبرته عددا
مرعبا للاطفال الذين فقدوا اهاليهم
ومنظمات الاغاثه سابق الزمن لتوفير الملجا
والرعايه لمن باتوا بلا ماوى
في اليوم هي التاسع من الزلزال ما زال
بالامكان تسجيل قصصي نجاح مشرقه لناجينا
من الموت تحت الانقاض حيث تمكنت فرق
الانقاذ في عده مناطق من انتشال احياء
عائشه ومحمد وباقي ورمضان وغيرهم كانوا
ابطال القصص هذا اليوم
من غايه بالانقاذ والركام وبعد نحو 220
ساعات على الزلزال تتوالى المعجزات
نهايات سعيده لعالقنا كتبت لهم الحياه من
جديد
في ولايه هاتاي وفي اليوم التاسع من
الكارثه نجحت فرق الانقاذ التركيه في
انتشال شخصين على قيد الحياه وهما من اسره
واحده كانت عالقه تحت الانقاض من بين عده
اشخاص التقت المسعفون اهاتهم وهذه سيده
تركيه تدعى عائشه جول بايير في الخامسه
والثلاثين من العمر اخرجت من باطن الارض
حيه ترزق
قضت عائشه وخمس ساعات تحت حطان منزلها
المهدم في ولايه كهرمان مراش مهمه شاقه
كللت بالنجاح بعد ان حفرت فرق الانقاذ
خندقا بطول خمسه امتار للوصول الى عائشه
ولان قصص نجاه العالقين هي ايضا قصص نجاح
المسعفين والمنقذين فهم لم يستطيعوا حبس
دموع الفرح
ومثل عائشه بضعه اخرون في مناطق متفرقه
في محافظه اديوان نجا الشاب محمد جيتين ذو
ثمانيه عشر عاما اذ اخرجه عمال الانقاذ
بعد ان ظل عالقا
199 ساعه كامله بينما يحدق محمد في ضوء
الشمس مجددا احاط به المسعفون قبل ان
ينقلوه الى المستشفى
وهنا في ولايه كهرمان مراش ايضا قصه نجاح
اخرى بل نجاح مزدوج حيث انتشل رجال
الانقاذ الشقيقين محمد انس يانينار 17 من
عمره وباقي نينار البالغه من العمر 21
عاما قال باقي انه ظل طوال الايام الماضيه
يشرب سائلا من مسحوق البروتين وهو مكمل
غذائي ساهم في ابقائه على قيد الحياه
هامش الامل يتضاءل ويتضائل لكن الاستثناء
يظل قائما خاصه لمن هم بصحه جيده وعلقوا
في جيوب امنه تحت الانقاض وبقربهم قليل من
الطعام والمياه
على اخر المستجدات واخر الاخبار
والمتابعات معنا من غاز عنتاب مراسل
الجزيره
يونس ياسين يوسينوس اهلا بك نشاهد الخيام
خلفك ماذا عن اهم رصدته في الساعات
الماضيه يونس
عبد القادر نحن نتواجد في احد المخيمات
المؤقته التي نصبتها بلديه غازي عنتاب
لاستقبال وايواء المتضررين من هذا الزلزال
الغازي عنتاب لا تبعد سوى 60 الى 70
كيلومتر عن كهرمان مراش بؤره الزلزال
وبالتالي فهذه الولايه توجد من ضمن
الولايات العشر التي تاثرت بهذا الزلزال
هناك يعني مدن مهدمه هناك بيوت متصدعه
الساكنوها وقاطنوها يخشون من العوده اليها
يعني في هذا المخيم توجد عشرات اكثر من
100 خيمه فيها يعني مئات الاسر المتزاحمه
داخل هذه الخيام السلطات التركيه والسلطات
المحليه في بلديه غازي عنتاب وفرت كل واحد
من ساكن هذه الخيمه وسائل تدفئه اليوم
رافقنا احدى الاسر في محاوله للتعرف على
كيف يتم اطعام هذا العدد الكبير من سكان
يعني هذه الخيام على بعد حوالي 400 متر
يوجد مطعم يعني هو احد افخم المطاعم في
ولايه غازي عنتاب والذي تحول الى بنك
للطعام يوفر مئات الالاف من الوجبات ليس
فقط لسكان هذا المخيم ولكن لعدد كبير من
سكان مدينه غازي عنتاب الذين يعني ليس
لديهم اي مورد اخر للطعام بحكم ان يعني
حوالي 90% وهذا تقدير شخصي للمحال يعني
المطاعم مقفله بسبب ان القائمين على هذه
المطاعم ايضا لهم هواجزهم الشخصيه منهم من
حاول اجلاء عائلته منهم من يخشى العوده
الى هذا المحل نظرا للتصدع المبنى الذي
يوجد فيه وبالتالي هناك مشكل حقيقي فيما
يتعلق بتوفير التغذيه التغذيه مشكله تم
حله وايضا تم حله على الاقل بالنسبه
لهؤلاء ويكفي ان نقول فقط انه قبل اسبوع
عبد القادر جل من تراهم الان
في الشاشه ربما تشاهد اطفال يلعبون الكره
في محاوله لاعاده ايقاع الحياه كما كان
قبل كنت تقول بان جل هؤلاء كانوا يبيتون
في العرائبتون في الساحات العامه خيام
يعني قطع بلاستيك اشعال للنار في الساحات
من اجل توفير التدفئه نحن اتحدث اليك عبد
القادر ودرجه الحراره الان الدرجه او
درجهتين تحت الصفر وبالتالي وقبل اسبوع
كانت درجه الحراره اقل انخفاضا وبالتالي
فواقعهم بالمقارنه مع ما كان عليه قبل
اسبوع قد تحسن بشكل كبير السؤال الان يطرح
الى متى سوف يبقون هنا الى متى سوف يعودون
الى بيوتهم وهذا يتوقف على اعمال لجان
البحث والتفتيش التي تجوب المدينه مدينه
غازي عنتاب على غرار المدن الاخرى
والولايات الاخرى حيث يتم مراقبه والكشف
عن هذه البيوت ومدى قدرتها على استيعاب
ساكنها يتم تصنيف هذه المباني هل هي متضرر
بشكل خفيف بشكل متوسط ام متضرره بشكل كامل
السلطات التركيه الرئيس التركي اليوم تحدث
عن ان واربعين الف مبنى الكره ضربت في
المصور
47 الف مبنى تاثر بسبب الزلزال عشرون الف
من هذه المباني صحيح انها لم تنهر بشكل
كامل لكن السلطات سوف تضطر الى هدمها
لانها يعني صحيح انها لم تتضرر لكنها لن
تكون قادره على استيعاب ساكنه وبالتالي
هناك مجهود يبذل السؤال الذي يطرحه هؤلاء
والى متى سوف يبقون في الخيام والحقيقه
انه لا احد يستطيع ان يجيبهم على هذا
السؤال هذا احد المظاهر والتجليات الباقيه
والمستمره فيما يتعلق بالزلزال بالاضافه
ايضا الى المتابعه الحثيثه لهؤلاء للقصص
هذه القصص التي وصفها تقرير زميل فتحي
اسماعيل بالمعجزه وهي معجزات متكرره
بالنظر الى انه نحن على بعد ساعات فقط من
دخول اليوم العاشر من الزلزال وما زالت
فرق الانقاذ تبحث وتنجح في اخراج الناجين
من تحت الانقاذ عبد القادر ما الذي سجلته
يونس وانت تحتك
بان سواء الذين تم تكفل بهم بشكل تدريجي
بتوفير الماوى وكذلك المطعم او ابرز
الانشغالات التي ما زالت مطروحه الى الان
ممن احتكيت بهم
عدد كبير من الانطباعات الشخصيه عبد
القادر لا ادري اذا كان المقام يسمح بها
لكن جوله بسيطه في هذا المخيم مثلا ترى
عدد من السيارات المركونه جنب الخيام
وبعضها سيارات فارهه وهذا يحيل بطبيعه
الحال الى ما لاحظته ايضا اليوم ايضا في
طوابير الطعام حيث تجد الغني والفقير كلهم
في طابور للطعام ينتظرون الحصول على وجبات
مجانيه اليوم ايضا في هذا المخيم حيث
تجولنا وجدنا يعني جمعيات ناشطه مهتمه
برعايه الاطفال تقوم بانشاء يعني انشطه
خاصه للاطفال ومحاوله التقرب اليهم وطرح
اسئله فيما يتعلق بالحاله التي يعيشون
فيها الاسئله التي يطرحها الاطفال لماذا
نحن هنا في المخيم ما الذي حدث اثناء
الزلزال هناك محاوله ومتابعه للحاله
النفسيه للاطفال وكيف اثر هذا الزلزال على
انفسهم هناك ايضا انشغالات امنيه احد
الذين تحدثنا اليهم في هذا المخيم قال
بانه هو واسرته الكبيره يعني اش وزوجته
وابنائه اخذوا ثلاثه قيام ويتناوبون واحد
منهم يقوم بالحراسه ليليا بالنظر الى وجود
هواجز امنيه هناك مخاوف من يعني ما يقال
عن جرائم منتشره هناك انتشار امني صحيح
لكن ربما التجارب علمتهم بانه الحس الامني
يجب ان يكون حاضرا بالاضافه الى الاسئله
المتعلقه بمستقبلهم ما الذي سوف يحدث لهم
هناك يعني محامون تاثرت مكاتبهم وضاعت
وثائق القضايا التي يعملون عليها يعني هذا
الزلزال حقيقه الاثار الفعليه له الاهتمام
بالاعلامي ربما خلال الفتره الماضيه تركز
على محاوله انقاذ العالقين محاوله اسعافهم
البحث عن المفقودين التاكد من يعني عمليه
الكشف عن المباني بالنظر الى الخطر الداهم
لها لكن سوف تبقى اثار اقتصاديه كبيره
يعني سوف ياخذ التعافي منها اجلا طويلا
عبد القادر
ياسين من احد مخيمات اللواء في غازي عنتاب
شكرا جزيلا لك
قال الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ان
زلزلين غير المسبوقين الذين ضرب البلاد
يوم الاثنين الماضي تسبب في مقتل ما يزيد
عن 35
الفارب مئه مواطن جاء ذلك في مؤتمر صحفي
للرئيس التركي عقب اجتماعي الحكومه
التركيه في مركز اداره الكوارث والطوارئ
في العاصمه التركيه انقره
تاثير الزلزلين انتشر على مساحه تزيد عن
مساحه بعض الدول وشمل تاثيرهما المباشر 10
محافظات تركيا لقد انتج طاقه تعادل مئات
القنابل النوويه
زلزاله كهرمان مرعش تسبب في خسائر كبيره
في الارواح والاموال وفي ازاحه الاراضي
التركيه لمسافه ثلاثه امتار نحو الجنوب
اؤكد لكم ان الدوله لن تترك مواطنيها سواء
الناجين منهم او النازحين دون رعايه
فاليوم يوم الوحده والتساند والتعاضد
مناطق كثيره في المحافظات التركيه
المنكوبه شهدت انهيارات ارضيه غير مسبوقه
وكبيره بسبب شده زلزال الذي ضرب المنطقه
مراسله الجزيره عبد العظيم محمد رصدا حجم
الدمار الكبير الذي خلفه الزلزال في مدينه
انطاكيا بولايه هاتايا تركيا
الصوره المشهد في
انطاكيا
حيث الدمار في كل مكان
والعمارات المدمره والبنايات العائله
للسقوط
مع ان اعمال
رفع الانقاذ تتواصل هذا البناء الذي
نتواجد فيه والابنيه المجاوره معظمها تم
اكتمال اعمال البحث فيها واخرجت جميع
الجثث التي كانت تحت الانقاض
وبقيت بقي فقط الركام في هذه المناطق نحن
في وسط مدينه انطاكيا مركز محافظه هاتاي
الدمار مهول جدا البنايات العائله للسقوط
اكثر من البنايات المدمره في اي لحظه انا
اقف امام عماره سكنيه مائله تماما وهي
مكونه من سته طوابق مائله تماما في اي
لحظه ممكن ان تسقط وبحسب وزاره البيئه
تحدثت انها عاينت 29
بنايه في مدينه
هاتاي حتى الان قالت ان هناك سته الاف
وثلث مئه من هذه البنايات هي يجب ازالتها
مشهد هاتاي مشهد انطاكيا ومختلف تماما عن
بقيه المشاهد الدمار فيها اوسع
الاصابات فيها اكثر
والوفيات فيها اكثر وهذا ينبا عن صعوبه
الاعمال والاعمال تتضاءل باخراج ناجين من
تحت الانقاذ
اسطنبول
لمعيكان نائبه مدير منظمه اوكسفان تركيا
اهلا بك سيده ديمركان نحن في اليوم التاسع
ما هي متابعاتكم لعمليات الانقاذ المتابعه
التكفل بالمنكوبين
[موسيقى]
نعم عمليات الانقاذ
الان تكون قد انتهت لانه ليس هناك امل
كبير عن انقاذ حياه تحت الانقاض نحن نركز
اكثر
على
الدعم لان الظروف في المناطق المنكوبه
ليست جيده
[موسيقى]
والبرد شديد
وبسبب
الصدمه بعد الزلزال الناس لا يريدون
العوده الى بيوتهم ما يزالون في الحدائق
او في السيارات او المسجد او قريبا من اي
نار طلبا لبعض الدفئه
وينتظرون ايضا
الملاجئ لكي يستقر فيها البعض لا يريدون
ان يغادروا بيوتهم بسبب مخاوف امنيه
يظلون قريبين من منازلهم لذلك يحتاجون بعض
المناجا التي
حتى تحميهم من البرد الشديد مثلا وبالتالي
امام هذا الوضع ما الذي
يتطور على صعيد الاداء في التكفل بكل هذه
الانشغالات والمطالب
الوقت الحاضر هناك
عمليه جمع
لحاجات الطارئه نريد تقييم في الارض
هناك
منظمات غير حكوميه تقوم بعمليات التقييم
ثم سوف نسعى الى ان
يصل جميع المنكوبين الى المساعدات اللازمه
السلطات الحكوميه وضعت
مخازن يتم تقديم او جمع المساعدات فيها
ونحن نسعى الى ان نضمن الى ان جميع
المنكوبين يمكنه ان يصل الى تلك المساعدات
ديمركان نحن في اليوم التاسع باعتقادك
هل تم
تجاوز الصدمه الاولى وبدا التفكير الان
بشكل افضل عما يجب فعله ماذا عن المراحل
الان والمرحله المتوسطه والمدى البعيد
عندما نتكفل عندما نتكلم عن التكفل بكل
هذه الاعداد الهائله من المنكوبين
سوء الحظ اعتقد
اننا ما نزال في مرحله الصدمه ونحاول ان
نفهم ما حدث
تقريبا الجميع في البلد فقدوا شخصا ما على
الاقل هناك
13 مليون ساكن في المنطقه المتضرره في عشر
مقاطعات اذا نحن في ما نزل في محاوله فهم
ما حدث ومدى اتساع الكارثه ونحن نفهم الان
الاثار التي
ستكون لهذا لهذه الكارثه على حياه الناس
اين سيبنون حياه جديده وهل سيبقون في
اماكن مدنهم هل سيغيرون عملهم
هل سيستمرون في الاماكن التي هم فيها ام
سينتقلون الى اماكن اخرى
الى اين سيذهب اطفالهم الى اي مدارس
ميزان هناك الكثير من المدن تم تدميرها
وحتى من المستشفيات
والمدارس اذا نحن نحتاج الى ان نفهم حقا
مدى فداحه
الاضرار وسيكون هناك بدايه جديده
لنرى ما هي الاولويات
للتخطيط للمدى الطويل عندما يتم الاتصال
بكم او التواصل بينكم وبين منظمات او جهات
دوليه ما الذي تطلبونه في هذه المرحله
نعرف مثلا انه سيكون هناك حاجه كبيره
لخيام
نريد مثلا
اماكن
للوجوب جاهزه البناء
وحمامات
وتقديم الخدمات الصحيه
والمياه والتسخين
كذلك اعاده بناء البنيه التحتيه
وجميع
المساعدات جيده ولكن ينبغي ان
يكون هناك ايضا مساهمات ماليه ونحن ممتنون
بان هناك مساعدات تاثيره من جميع انحاء
العالم
من فرنسا
يسالوننا مثلا كيف يمكننا ان نساعده وماذا
تحتاجون منا وما نقول لهم ان
دعم المالي يمكننا من بعض المرونه لكي
نستجيب للحاجات الاساسيه
شكرا لك كنت معنا من اسطنبول نائبه مدير
منظمه اوكسفا من تركيا السيده ديمركان
شكرا جزيلا لك
هذا وتعالي المستشفيات التركيه في المناطق
المنكوبه من زياده عدد المصابين مراسله
الجزيره المعتز بالله حسن ليطلعنا على
الوضع من داخل احد مشافي مدينه كهرمان
نحن هنا في واحد من المشافي التابعه
للدوله اي للقطاع العام في هذا المشفى
طبعا ما تراه خلفي هو ليس كله من الناجين
لان هذه المستشفى وهذا قسم العاجل
وبالتالي هناك عده حالات هنا على الارض
يمكن ان نلاحظ تقسيم الخطوط وفق اولويه
الحاله التي تاتي الى هذا المكان وبالتالي
سهوله نقلها عبر هذا المكان الى المناطق
الاخرى سواء كان ذلك لاجراء الفحص بالاشعه
او اي شيء اخر يمكن من خلاله ان يتم
معالجه هذه الحاله وبعد تحقيق الاستقرار
فيها حاله المصاب يتم نقله الى مشافي اكبر
ربما سواء في مدينه انقره او في مدينه
اسطنبول القائمون على هذا المشفى اخبروني
انها اكثر من الفي حاله من المصابين في
كهرمان مراش جاءت الى هذا المشفى وتم
تحقيق التدخل الاولي بحيث
تحقيق الاستقرار في الحاله ومن ثم نقلها
الى مشافي اخرى هذه حاله اخرى قد تكون
لحادثه ما ليست ربما من النقاط لكن هي
فرصه لارى ماذا في الداخل كما تشاهد هناك
الكثير من الحالات موجوده في هذا المكان
هناك محاوله لتحقيق الاستقرار في الحالات
وايضا هناك ضغط على هذه الاقسام في هذا
المشفى وهذا الحال هو الحال نفسه في كل
المشافي الاخرى في هذه المناطق اكثر من
الفي حاله كما ذكرت والاطباء اداره المشفى
اخبرتني ان اكثر من 90% من الاطباء في هذه
المشفى تركوا منذ بدايه الزلزال
عائلاتهم وجاوي لهذا المكان ليشاركوا وما
زالوا يشاركونا في اعمال الانقاذ ومحاوله
استقرار الحالات ايضا بحسب ما فهمت ان
الوضع الان في العاجل هو استقر نوعا ما
لانه لم يعد هناك الكثير ممن يخرجون من
تحت الالقاب
ومع مرور الوقت بعد زلزال كاران مارش
يتكشف مزيد من الماسي تحت انقاذ احد
الفنادق في اديمان قتل عدد من الطلاب
كانوا ضمن فريق الكره الطائره من قبرص
الشماليه
شارع هادئ مخصص للمشاه فقط مقاهي صغيره
تنتشر هنا وهناك لا يزال يعقوب يتحدث عن
مدينته المنكوبه بصيغه الحاضر
يهوى الرجل التصوير قبل يوم من الزلزال
وبينما الثلج يتساقط وثق الساعات الاخيره
قبيل الفاجعه
هكذا كان احد اشهر الفنادق في ادياما
وهكذا اصبح
كان هناك طلاب من قبرص الشماليه علقوا تحت
الانقاض اتت فرق انقاذ وحاولت انتشالهم
حاولنا ايضا المساعده
اذن انهيار الفندق الى مقتل اكثر من 100
شخص بينهم طلاب في فريق للكره الطائره من
قبرص الشماليه قتل الفريق باكمله تحت
انقاذ هذا المبنى حاولنا العثور على اي
اثر تركه الضحايا خلفهم الدمار اخفى كل
شيء لكنه لم يمحو ذكراهم فتلك باقيه في
قلوب عائلتهم الحزن جاوز حدود تركيا
نجحنا في التواصل مع عائلتي احد الطلاب
فقدنا 35 شخصا من فماجستا الجميع اقرباء
واصدقاء نعيش كارثه وكان قنبله نوويه
القيت علينا
على وقع الم الخساره الكبير استعادت عائله
الطلاب جثامنهم انتشلتهم فرق البحث من تحت
الانقاض اقيمت الصلاه عليهم في اديمان ثم
نقل جوا الى قبرص ليدفنوا قرب عائلاتهم
قصه تلخص حاله كثيرين تزامن وجودهم في
تركيا مع وقوع الزلزال ولم تكتب لهم
النجاه
سلام خضر الجزيره اليمن
[موسيقى]
هذا في تركيا اما في سوريا فالجدل بشان
دخول المساعدات الى مناطق المعارضه
السوريه في شمال الغربي البلاد مستمر فبعد
اعلان الامم المتحده موافقه الرئيس السوري
بشار الاسد استخدام معبرين اضافيين قال
الدفاع المدني في شمال سوريا ان ذلك منح
النظام مكاسب سياسيه مجانيه
على مرمى البصر يمتد الدمار الذي خلفه
الزلزال في شمال غربي سوريا حل دمار
الزلزال فوق دمار الحرب ليخلف وضعا يتفق
الجميع على انه كارثي لكن هذا الاجماع لا
يتحقق عندما يتعلق الامر بسبل مواجهته
انتظرت الامم المتحده سته ايام لارسال اول
قافله مساعدات وانتظرت بضعه ايام اخرى
ليصل وفد يمثلها الى المناطق المنكوبه
للاطلاع على الحاجات الانسانيه بعد
الزلزال اطلق الامين العام للامم المتحده
نداء لتمويل الاحتياجات الانسانيه
للمتضررين في سوريا الذين قدر عددهم بتسعه
ملايين
اعلن اطلاق الامم المتحده نداء لجمع ما
قيمته
397 مليون دولار من اجل تقديم مساعدات
انسانيه للمتضررين من الزلزال في سوريا
وسيغطي هذا فتره تمتد ثلاثه اشهر
لا يعرف هل سيثير تقسيم هذه المساعدات
جدلا كالذي تثيره المعابر الان فقبل هذا
الاعلان اعلن غوتيريج عن موافقه الرئيس
السوري بشار الاسد على مرور المساعدات عبر
المعابر مع تركيا واكد ذلك وكيله للشؤون
الانسانيه
نرسل المساعدات الى شمال غربي سوريا منذ
سنوات عده وقرروا الاسدي باضافه مع
برين حجم
الحاجه
اعطاء الاسد سلطه على مرور المساعدات عبر
المعابر مع تركيا واعلان سماحه باستخدام
معبرين اضافيين اغضبت الدفاع المدني
السوري في شمال سوريا قال مديره رائد صالح
ان ذلك منح النظام مكاسب سياسيه مجانيه
اما وحده تنسيق الدعم التابعه للائتلاف
الوطني السوري المعارض فقد دعت الامم
المتحده والمجتمع الدولي لتحمل مسؤولياتهم
واعتبار شمال غرب سوريا منطقه منكوبه اذا
يستمر الجدل بشان المعابر رغم حجم الكارثه
التي خلفها الزلزال فخلال الفتره الاخيره
سمح بدخول المساعدات من معبر باب الهوى
دون غيره لان الامم المتحده لم تمنح
تفويضا بذلك بسبب رفض روسيا بالخصوص التي
تعتبر استخدام هذه المعابر انتهاكا
للسياده السوريه
ورغم ان النظام اعلن من قبل انه سيسمح
بمرور المساعدات من مناطق سيطرته الى
مناطق المعارضه فان ذلك لم يحدث حتى الان
هذه قافله امميه اخرى تدخل من معبر باب
الهوى وتتالف من اثنتين وثلاثين شاحنه
تحمل مواد اغاثيه مختلفه وهذه اول قافله
تدخل من معبر باب السلامه الى شمال سوريا
بعد موافقه النظام لا يبدو ان ايقاع دخول
هذه المساعدات يتناسب مع حجم الاحتياجات
في شمال غربي سوريا فهناك يعيش نحو اربعه
ملايين ونصف مليون سوري اصبحوا كلهم
تقريبا في حاجه الى مساعدات لكن بالنسبه
لهم المساعدات الانسانيه لا تصل حسب
حاجتهم وانما وفق حسابات سياسيه لم تهتم
يوما بحجم الكوارث
الخارجيه الامريكيه قال ان هناك حاجه الى
فتح المزيد من المعابر على الحدود السوريه
التركيه واضاف انه لا عذر ابدا لعدم المضي
قدما في هذا الصدد اما المندوبه الامريكيه
بمجلس الامن ليندا توماس فقد شددت على
ضروره ان يراقب المجلس تنفيذ اتفاق فتح
معبرين اضافيين لادخال المساعدات
الانسانيه الى سوريا
ان اي تقدم لايصال المساعدات الى الشعب
السوري يعد امرا ضروريا يجب علينا ضمان
عدم ايقاف المساعدات بقرار لمجلس الامن من
شانه ان يضمن ذلك ما نخطط القيام به حاليا
هو مراقبه تنفيذ الاتفاق بجديه اذا كانت
المساعده تتدفق بطريقه غير مقيده وحصل
الاشخاص على المساعده التي يحتاجونها
فسيكون ذلك جيدا لكن علينا ان نراقب لنرى
ما سيحدث استغرق اتخاذ هذا القرار سبعه
اياما للسماح بفتح الحدود كان ينبغي اتخاذ
هذا القرار في اليوم الاول
بنجربها اعتبرت روزيدياز المتحدث
الاقليميه باسم الحكومه البريطانيه في
حديث مع الجزيره ان موافقه دمشق على
استخدام معبرين جديدين الى شمال غربي
سوريا جاءت متاخره جدا
الان نوافر
3.8 مليون جنيه الى
البعده
لدعم عمليات البحث والانقاذ وايضا
المعادلات الطبيه
ونستمر مع هذه المساعده والان ايضا
نرسلبيه
[موسيقى]
لاعاده فتره المدارس والطرق وكمان اعاده
ربط الخدمات وكل هذه المساعدات بريطانيا
هي جاهزه لتوفير المتضررين في المنطقه
وايضا خاصه في شمال الغرب سوريا
معنا من اعزاز في حلب مراسل الجزيره عمر
حوراني عمر اذا في ظل اشتداد هذا الجدل
فيما يتعلق بهذه المساعدات والامم المتحده
ما الذي رصدته من انطباعات الناس واهم ما
سجلته في الساعات الماضيه في هذا اليوم
نعم خلال دقائق الماضيه كانت هنا قافله
تعبر هذا الطريق هذا الطريق المتجه باتجاه
جنديرس هذه القافله التي هي من عشر شاحنه
من عشرات الشاحنات هي واصله من مساعدات من
شرق الفرات من عشائر دير الزور وهذه ما
يقول هنا المدنيين انها هي اكثر بكثير من
المساعدات المقدمه
قد تكون نشاهد احدى هذه الشاحنات التي
ما زالت تعبر هذا الطريق باتجاه جنديرس
اذا هي العشرات من الشاحنات التي عبرت عبر
هذا الطريق باتجاه جنديرس وهي مقدمه وهي
مساعدات من الاهالي وهي تعبر عن التكافل
الاجتماعي وسط خذلان ما قالوا عنه انه
خذلان دولي اتجاه تقديم المساعدات هنا احد
المشرفين على هذه القافله نستطيع الحديث
معه لو تحدثنا عن هذه حياكم الله بسم الله
والصلاه والسلام على خير خلق الله اخي
وصلت قوافل ابناء عشائر محافظه دير الزور
اهل النخوه واهل الكرامه وعزوتنا هذا ما
عجزت عنه وهذه القافله تضم اكثر من 100
قاطره مقطوره هذا ما عجزت عنه جامعه للاسف
جامعه الدول العربيه ومجلس الامن الدولي
عجز عن هذه المساعدات بل سارعوا الى
مساعدات النظام
النصيري الطاغيه وكل
طيب جميع ابناء عمر شائر
محافظ عمر اخي الكريم طبعا نفهم نفهم غضب
نفهم غضب الناس ولكن انت رصدت ايضا
والتقيت بالكثير من الناس واكيد رصدت
انشغالاتهم نداءاتهم في ظل هذا الوضع
القاسي الذي يعيشه السكان في هذه الاماكن
نعم تماما هذا ما رصدناه هذا اليوم كان
هناك جانب كبير من المبادرات المحليه
رصدنا جانب من المبادرات لمتطوعين بالدفاع
المدني الان تحولوا وهم المتطوعات من رفع
الانقاذ الى اتجهوا الى تضميد جراح من هم
نجوا من هذا الزلزال شاهدناهم يتنقلوا بين
الخيام لتضميد وتغيير على جراح من اصيبه
وايضا هناك مبادرات لتقديم الاغذيه لهؤلاء
الذين يفترشون الطرقات كما ان هناك مبادره
للايواء وايضا هذه نتحدث عن دخول
المساعدات دخل هذا اليوم 11 شاحنه من معبر
باب السلامه الا ان الجهات المعنيه هنا
تحدثت انه ليس الاولويه هو فتح المعابر بل
الاولويه هي ايجاد هذه المساعدات هذا
المعبر قد فتح وفتح معبر راعي ايضا الا ان
هذه المعابر لم يدخل منها سوى 11 سياره
النقص ليس بالمعابر النقص
بحاجه النقص بالحاجيات النقص بميزانيه
لهذه المساعدات التي من المفترض كانت ان
تاتي منذ الايام الاولى الا انه تاخرت حتى
اليوم السادس حتى بدات دخول هذه المساعدات
وهذه المساعدات دخلت بعشرات السيارات فقط
وهي لا تكفي شيئا مقارنه بحجم المعاناه
التي تشهدها المنطقه جراء الزلزال
عمر حوراني شكرا جزيلا لك
اذا دخل اليوم اول وفد اممي رفيع المستوى
الى مناطق شمال غربي سوريا من معبر باب
الهوى الحدودي مع تركيا وهو ما يعيد تسليط
الضوء على اليه عمل الامم المتحده
واستجابتها في هذه المنطقه خلال وقبل
الزلزال تبع زلزال كهرمان مرعش
كيف تصل المساعدات المقدمه من الامم
المتحده الى مستحقيها في شمال غرب سوريا
تعتمد المنظمه الدوليه ببرامجها المتنوعه
على منظمات سوريه تعمل على الارض وتكون
هذه المنظمات شريكا للامم المتحده بعد
استيفائها شروطا ومعايير معينه بدايه كيف
كانت اليه العمل في شمال سوريا بعد حدوث
زلزال كهرمان مراش تقول منظمات عامله على
الارض انها اجره بواسطه فرقها مسحا اوليا
بمنطقتنا واكثر ضربها الزلزال وذلك
بالتعاون مع جهات عامله هناك مجالس
المحليه واداره المخيمات وغيرها هذا المسح
يرمي الى جمع معلومات تتعلق بالاحتياجات
العاجله مثل اقامه مخيم جديد وتقديم
مساعدات غذائيه وطبيه وغير ذلك ثم تقدم
قائمه الاحتياجات هذه لهيئات الامم
المتحده المعنيه بالمساعدات المطلو
قبل الزلزال كانت كل منظمه شريكه مع الامم
المتحده لديها قائمه معلومات تتعلق بعدد
المشمولين بالمساعده من سكان المنطقه او
من بين النازحين وبعدد الاطفال والنساء
والمرضى وقائمه بالمواد والخدمات المطلوبه
مساعدات الامم المتحده تكون في مخازن
التابعه لها في مدينه الريحانيه التركيه
قرب الحدود مع سوريا تنطلق شاحنات سوريه
عبر معبر باب الهوى الى تلك المخازن لشحن
المساعدات ونقلها الى سوريا ويجري تسليمها
لكل منظمه شريكه للام المتحده كل حسب
مخصصاتها
[موسيقى]
هذا وقال المتحدث باسم الامين العام
للاممي المتحده ان قوافل المنظمه الدوليه
لم تواجه اي مشاكل عند مرورها عبر معبر
باب السلامه الحدودي لايصال المساعدات
الانسانيه للسوريين واكد دوجاريك ان الامم
المتحده تعمل على تقييم حاله معبر الراعي
وانها متفائله بشان استخدام المعبر بشكل
سلس وسريع
اي مشكلات في الواقع سارت الامور على ما
يرام هذا الصباح لدينا فريق تقييم في
الموقع الثالث معبر الراعي لمعرفه مدى
السرعه التي يمكننا من خلالها تشغيله
لكننا متفائل جدا بان الامور ستتحرك بسرعه
كما قلنا تم استخدام الكثير من هذه
المعابر من قبل منظمات اغاثه غير تابعه
للامم المتحده والطرق المؤديه اليها في
حاله افضل من طريق معبر باب الهوى
من شمال ادلب معنا فراس الخليفه المتطوع
في الدفاع المدني السوري سيد فراس ماذا عن
طبيعه مهامكم الان تتكلم عن اليوم التاسع
بعد الزلزال
نعم السلام عليكم ما تزال فرق الدفاع
المدني السوري الخوذ البيضاء تنتشر وتعمل
في اكثر من موقع من المواقع التي دمرت
نتيجه الزلزال
الكارثه الذي حل في المنطقه في السادس من
فبراير
تقوم الان فرقنا بعمليات البحث وانتشار
الضحايا من تحت الركام تنتظر بلاغات
المدنيين عن وجود مفقودين لهم لتقوم
وتسارع بالبحث بالاماكن التي يشير اليها
المدنيون يوم امس اتان حوالي عشر بلاغات
في منطقه واحده في منطقه جنديرس عن وجود
مفقودين لهم استطعنا ايجاد حالتين تحت
الانقاط كانوا قد توفوا صراحه الوضع صعب
حاليا لكن
تحاول فرقنا العمل والبقاء في جميع
المواقع التي دمرت فيها المباني السكنيه
فوق روسيا ساكنيها لتحقق اسرع استجابه في
حال الابلاغ عن اي مفقود او اي شخص من
اقارب العائلات التي كانت خارج تلك
المناطق وعادت اليها لتطمئن
عن دخول او بدايه دخول او دخول المساعدات
ما الذي تحتاجونه انتم كمعدات كفرق دفاع
مدني
مع قرب انتهاء حالات البحث
وانتشار الضحايا سننتقل الى المرحله
الثانيه وهي مرحله ازاله الانقاض وفتح
الطرقات ثم يليها مرحله اعاده بناء هذه
المباني السكنيه ليعود الناس اليها لتعود
الحياه الى هذه المكان هذه الاماكن طبعا
الاحتياجات كبيره كل مرحله تحتاج الى
معدات تحتاج الى اليات تحتاج الى مساعدات
مختلفه مساله اعاده ازاله الانقاض تحتاج
الى معدات واليات كبيره جرافات كبيره لكي
يستطيع ازاله الالقاب الكبيره والكثيره
التي
انتشرت في عده مواقع في عموم مناطق شمال
غرب سوريا في جنديرس وشمال ادلب وارياف
حلب ايضا مرحله فتح الطرقات ومرحله اعاده
بناء المباني تحتاج الى دعم كبير سواء
للمنظمات الانسانيه العامله التي يمكنها
ان تقوم بهذه المشاريع او لاي جهه المهم
لدينا هو اعاده الحياه لهؤلاء المدنيين
لهم او هجره منها ايضا هناك احتياجات
لتحديد المباني المتصدعه هناك اكثر من 40
الف عائله تركت منازلها نتيجه تصدع
المباني السكنيه التي يعيشون بها ايضا من
الضروري وجود فرق فرق مجهزه بادوات حديثه
تساعد الدفاع المدني السوري ونقابه
المهندسين من اجل تحديد المباني المتضرره
ودرجه الخطر فيها وهل يمكن الم العوده
اليها او كيف سيتم تدعيمها او اعاده اعاده
بناءها من جديد من اجل عوده المدني
المعلومه سيد فراس هل جرى الاتصال بكم من
قبل منظمات دوليه او جهات دوليه للاطلاع
على احتياجاتكم وانتم من تعرفون الميدان
والواقعه بشكل افضل
نعم صراحه المنظمات الداعمه للدفاع المدني
السوري والجهات الداعمه له الموجوده في
بريطانيا امريكا
الدول الاوروبيه الدنمارك قطر السعوديه
كان هناك اتصال دائم من اجل تحديد ما هي
احتياجات الدفاع المدني السوري القوات
البيضاء ما هي احتياجاته في كل مرحله يعمل
بها قمنا برفع احتياجاتنا والتي تساعد
وتساهم في اعاده الحياه للمدنيين في
المنطقه
والكثير ومعظم داعمونا وعدونا
الدعم قصير المدى وطويل المدى من اجل
المساهمه اكبر
بحفظ حياه المدنيين او اعاده الحياه لهم
في المناطق المتضرره
من شمال ادلب فراس الخليفه المتطوع في
الدفاع المدنيه السوري شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
قدرت الامم المتحده ان اكثر من سبعه
ملايين طفل تاثروا بالزلزال المدمر
والهزات الارتداديه التي اعقبته في كل من
تركيا وسوريا واعربت منظمه الامم المتحده
للطفوله يونيسيف عن مخاوف من ان يكون الاف
الاطفال قد لقوا حتفهم في البلدين بفعل
زلزال كهرمان مرش وكذلك بفعل التوابعه
يلا يا بابا
فيل ذات الكبد
لا يتالم لضر يصيبها فكيف بفقدها
يخشى ان الاف الاطفال الاتراك والسوريين
قد قضوا في كارثه الزلزال الامم المتحده
التي تقول ذلك تتوقع ان الحصيده النهائيه
ستكون مرعبه لم يخلو المشهد من لحظات
تبتهج فيها الملايين وتبكي في ان معه
الحمد لله يحدث ان تخرج القلوب الصغيره
خفاقه من تحت الانقاض لكن سرعان ما نواجه
معها حيره السؤال المحتوم عن اليوم التالي
تقدر عموم المتحده ان اكثر من سبعه ملايين
طفل تاثروا بالزلزال بكل من تركيا وسوريا
ففي المحافظات التركيه العشر المتضرره كان
يعيش ما مجموعه اربعه ملايين الف طفل
بينما تشير التقديرات الامميه الى تاثر
مليونين ونصف المليون طفل في سوريا
الاثر باق بالرغم من النجاه الموصوفه في
احيينا كثيره بالمعجزه
فطفوله هؤلاء تعبر الى محنه جديده تشكلها
الاصابه او الصدمه او فقد الاهل والماوى
او جميعها معها
تقول هذه السيده ان ابنائها باتوا يرددون
ان طفولتهم قد ضاعت
الحقيقه ان معظم الاطفال الناجين من كوارث
مماثله تهزهم في الغالب صدمات نفسيه او
اعراض ما بعد الصدمه
تلقي العلاج النفسي والدعم الفردي
والجماعي قد يكون متاحا للاطفال المتضررين
في تركيا اكثر مما هو بنسبه لاقرانهم في
سوريا
وجه الاختلاف الاخر بين الحالتين مرتبط
بمصير الاطفال الذين كتبت لهم النجاه ولم
تكتب لذويهم
يؤكد نائب الرئيس التركي ان 574 طفلا
انتشلوا من انقاض مباني منهاره وجدوا بدون
اهاليهم ويضيف فؤاد اقطاعي ان 76 منهم فقط
اجتمعوا لاحقا بافراد من عائلاتهم مع ذلك
تبدو الحاله السوريه اشد سوءا فالى اين
يوجه يتامى الزلزال هناك من الاطفال
الى دور الايتام المكتظه في الاساس ام الى
بقيه اهل في بقعه ما من ارض سوريا
شتت الحرب كما نعلم شمل العائلات السوريه
خلال العقد الماضي مما يعقد الان عمليه
العثور على اقرباء للاطفال الناجين من
الزلزال حتى الناجون مع اهلهم لا يخرجوا
سريعا من دائره المعاناه
فالمااول المؤقته لن تغني عن دفء البيت
المفقود
وتقبل العقول الصغيره وضعها الجديد سيحتاج
لبعض الوقت
هذا وحذر المدير الاقليمي لمنظمه الصحه
العالميه في اوروبا هانس من التابعات
الصحيه لزلزال كهرمان مراش وفي مقدماتها
انتشار الاوبئه والامراض المعديه واكد
وقوفا المنظمه الى جانب السلطات الصحيه
التركيه في مواجهه تلك التحديات
بعد مرور اكثر من اسبوع على هذه الماساه
الرهيبه تزداد المخاوف بشان القضايا
الصحيه المرتبطه بالطقس البارد والنظافه
والصرف الصحي وانتشار الامراض المعديه
كلها تحدق بالاشخاص الاكثر عرضه للخطر
بشكل خاص اذانا نقف الى جانب السلطات
الصحيه التركيه فقد ابلغون بارسال امدادات
اللقاحات شديده الاهميه بما في ذلك
التطعيمات ضد الكزاز وداء الكلب الى منطقه
الزلزال وبمباشره الصيدليات المتنقله
عملها هناك
كما وصف كلوجي الزلزال الذي ضرب كلا من
تركيا وسوريا بانه اكبر كارثه طبيعيه منذ
قرن تضرب بلدا واقعا في منطقه الفرع
الاوروبي من منظمه الصحه العالميه والتي
تضم من بينها تركيا
يظهر المجتمع الدولي الكرم نفسه الذي
اطهرته تركيا لدول العالم على مر السنين
هذا البلد موطن لاكبر عدد من اللاجئين في
العالم لدينا اكثر من اربعه ملايين شخص من
سوريا المجاوره وقد فقد الكثير منهم مجددا
كل شيء اننا نشهد اسوا كارثه طبيعيه في
منطقه الفرع الاوروبي لمنظمه الصحه
العالميه منذ قرن
ما هي من القاهره ريتشارد برينال مدير
الطوارئ للمكتبه الاقليمي بمنظمه الصحه
العالميه اهلا بك سيد علمت انك قد عدت من
سوريا قبل قليل هل لك ان تصف لنا او تنقل
لنا
مشاهداتك بايجاز
نعم كان هناك
مشاهد
للدمار
ونتيجه لزلزال
وهناك مباني عديده مدمره
وتقريبا 350 الف شخصا بدون
ماوى بسبب الزلزال
ماذا عن تقييمك للجانب الصحي الاحتياجات
الصحيه في المناطق التي زرتها
الامر خطير جدا
كنا في مناطق الحكوميه تحت الحكومه في
اللاذقيه وغيرها هناك الاف الموتى
والاصابات
هناك من نجروا ولكنهم تعرضوا لاصابات
عديده
وفي الوقت نفسه لدينا الان مئات
الالاف من الناس بدون
منازل في اجواء بارده جدا
والان والماوى
وهم ياخذون الليله في
المساجد وغيرها وايضا ظروف صحيه
سيئه جدا
وعدم تتميز بعدم الوصول الى المياه الشرب
والوضع طبعا سيء جدا وبدانا نرى
انتشار بعض الاوبئه
وبالاضافه الى تلك الظروف
هناك الكثير من الحالات النفسيه فيما بعد
الصدمه
وهؤلاء الناس
في منطقه النزاع منذ 12 عاما
والاقتصاد
متدهور وكثيرون يعيشون تحت مستوى الفقر
وهناك امراض وهناك ايضا وباء الكوليرا اذا
كانت كان اعصارا حقيقيا للشعب السوري
والمعاناه شديده جدا ارجو ان تبقى معي
لانقل هذا الخبر العاجل عن انقاذ رجل يبلغ
من العمر 77 عاما في اديمان جنوبي تركيا
بعد 212 ساعه على زلزال اي بعد تسعه ايام
اذا رجل يبلغ العمر 77 عاما وهذا خبر مفرح
جدا اعود لك سيد برينام انت الان زرت هذه
الاماكن خرجت بهذا التصور الان ماذا يمكن
لمنظمه الصحه العالميه ان تفعله حيال هذا
الوضع المعقب سواء في منا النظام او في
اماكن سيطره المعارضه في الشمال الغربيه
السوري
قمنا بالكثير في الشمال الغربي حيث وزعنا
طنا من المواد الطبيه
ووزعنا ايضا اكثر من سبعين طنا في المناطق
الحكوميه
ومناطق نشاتنا الاخرى هي
دعم تقديم
الدعم النفسي
وانتشرنا في منطقه الشمال الغربي وقد
ذكرته من قبل
ان هناك مخاطر
لانتشار اوبئه وحتى قبل الزلزال كان هناك
نحن نعمل مع السلطات الصحيه
للتاكد انها لا تنتشر هذه الاوبئه اكثر
ونوفر الظروف اللازمه للتعامل مع ذلك
كان هناك
مستشفيات عديده فقط هناك نقطه تحتاج الى
توضيح ما ذكرته من دخول مساعدات الى
الاماكن في الشمال الغربي السوري هي
مساعدات تم اقرارها بعد وقوع الزلزال ام
انها ضمن المساعدات الدوريه نتيجه هذه
الاماكن تقع في مناطق حرب يعني انها
مساعدات مبرمجه من قبل وليست بعد الزلزال
به في شمال غرب سوريا
التي هي منطقه غير مستقره بشكل كبير هو
اننا لدينا معدات
طبيه موجوده هناك ومواد طبيه
مئه من
المواد الطبيه وما ان حدث زلزال حتى
شركاؤنا وصلوا الى مخازننا واخذوا هذه
المواد لتوزيعها وبعدها ذلك وصلت كميه الى
190 طنا وهناك فرق اخرى
تسعى الى تقديم المزيد من الدعم
شكرا جزيلا لك من القاهره مدير الطوارئ
المكتبه الاقليمي بمنظمه الصحه العالميه
شكرا
قصص انسانيه وازمات نفسيه كثيره خلفها هذا
الزلزال الضخم في تركيا طالت حتى ان جينا
من هول الكارثه جانب من هذه القصص تتابعه
في التقرير التالي
سيده تركيه نجت مع اطفالها الثلاثه من
الكارثه تبني لها حياه جديده في الشارع
اهمها الاول هو ان يتلقى اطفالها رعايه
واهتماما وبيئه حاضنه تجهلهم اكثر شجاعه
وقادرين على تحمل الصدمه
تعودنا مشاهده الزلازل والكوارث المماثله
على شاشه التلفزيون لم نتخيل ابدا اننا
سنمر بهذا يوما ما
لكل طفل قصه ومشهد صعب عاشوا تحت الانقاض
ليس من السهل محوه ولا تجاوزه الا بالدعم
النفسي المتخصص
السيدهولاي تحاول تقديم هذا الدعم لافراد
اسرتها وقد اصبحوا على قارعه الطريق
لقد دمر انفسهم يقولون لا نريد ان نعيش
هكذا اريد غرفتي اريد العابي اريد ان اعيش
في منزلي ننجح في ايجاد طريقه لتعزيتهم
قصه مؤثره اخرى في موقع مختلف في تقيم
عائله نجم الدين دي ميرسي امام مبنى منهار
وقد وضعت صوره احد اطفالها المفقودين على
جذع شجره علها تجد من يتعرف عليه
لم يعثر على اي اثر لاقارب حتى الان هناك
ثمانيه اشخاص بالداخل ولا توجد اخبار عنهم
على الاطلاق
هزه ارضيه امتدت ثواني معدوده وخلفت ماسيا
جما حتى للناجين وحياه تحولت في غمضه عين
الى ازمات نفسيه كبيره قد تلازم بعضهم
طوال حياتهم انهم اليوم معرضون لما يعرف
برهاب زلازل
اذكر بخبر انقاذ رجل يبوي العمر 77 عاما
في منطقه اليامان جنوبيه تركيا بعد
212 ساعه من وقوع الزلزال راس الساعه
منتصف الليل بتوقيت مكه المكرمه تذكير
بالعناوين في هذه التغطيه المستمره
في اليوم التاسع للزلزال اخراج ناجين من
تحت الانقاض في مناطق عده السلطات التركيه
تعلن تجاوز عدد القتلى 35 الفا ونزوح اكثر
من مليوني شخص
منظمه الصحه العالميه تعتبر الزلزال اسوا
كارثه طبيعيه في اوروبا منذ قرن وتحذر من
تفشي الامراض
وسط انتقادات بسبب تناسب المساعدات مع
الاحتياجات نداء اممي لجمع نحو 400 مليون
دولار لمساعده ضحايا الزلزال في سوريا
دخول اول قافله مساعدات دوليه عبر معبر
باب السلامه بعد قرار فتح معبرين اضافيين
تنتقل تاخر فتح المعبرين وتطالب بفتح
المزيد لايصال المساعدات للمتضررين
السوريين
في التداعيات الانسانيه الامم المتحده
تقول ان اكثر من سبعه ملايين طفل تاثروا
بالزلزال في تركيا وسوريا اليونيسف تخشى
مقتل الاف منهم وتحذر مما اعتبرته عددا
مرعبا للاطفال الذين فقدوا اهاليهم
ومنظمات الاغاثه سابق الزمن لتوفير الملجا
والرعايه لمن باتوا بلا ماوى
اذا في اليوم التاسع من الزلزال ما زال
بالامكان تسجيل قصصي نجاح مشرقه لناجينا
من الموت تحت الانقاض حيث تمكنت فرق
الانقاذ في عده مناطق من انتشال احيام
اسماء عائشه ومحمد وباقي ورمضان وغيرهم
كانوا ابطال هذا اليوم وقبل قليل تكلمنا
عن رجل يبلغ العمر 77 عاما في اديمان كان
من بين الناجين يتابع
من غياه بالانقاذ والركام وبعد نحو 220
ساعات على الزلزال تتوالى المعجزات
نهايات سعيده لعالقين كتبت لهم الحياه من
جديد
في ولايه هاتاي وفي اليوم التاسع من
الكارثه نجحت فرق الانقاذ التركيه في
انتشال شخصين على قيد الحياه وهما من اسره
واحده كانت عالقه تحت الانقاض من بين عده
اشخاص التقت المسعفون اهاتهم وهذه سيده
تركيه تدعى عائشه جول بايير في الخامسه
والثلاثين من العمر اخرجت من باطن الارض
حيه ترزق
قضت عائشه
تحت حطام منزلها المهدم في ولايه كهرمان
مراش مهمه شاقه كللت بالنجاح بعد ان حفرت
فرق الانقاذ خندقا بطول خمسه امتار للوصول
الى عائشه ولان قصص نجاه العالقين هي ايضا
قصص نجاح المسعفين والمنقذين فهم لم
يستطيعوا حبس دموع الفرح
ومثل عائشه بضعه اخرون في مناطق متفرقه
في محافظه اديوان نجا الشاب محمد جيتين ذو
ثمانيه عشر عاما اذ اخرجه عمال الانقاذ
بعد ان ظل عالقا
199 ساعه كامله بينما يحدق محمد في ضوء
الشمس مجددا احاط به المسعفون قبل ان
ينقلوه الى المستشفى
وهنا في ولايه كهرمان مراش ايضا قصه نجاح
اخرى بل نجاح مزدوج حيث انتشل رجال
الانقاذ الشقيقين محمد انس يانينار 17 من
عمره وباقي نينار البالغه من العمر 21
عاما قال باقي انه ظل طوال الايام الماضيه
يشرب سائلا من مسحوق البروتين وهو مكمل
غذائي ساهم في ابقائه على قيد الحياه
هامش الامل يتضاءل ويتضائل لكن الاستثناء
يظل قائما خاصه لمن هم بصحه جيده وعلقوا
في جيوب امنه تحت الانقاض وبقربهم قليل من
الطعام والمياه
وهذه هي صور تم تصويرها قبل قليل للخبر
اذا اضعناه قبل قليل عن التمكن من انقاذ
رجل يبلغ من العمر سبعه وسبعين عاما جنوبي
تركيا في منطقه اديمام تم انقاذه في هذا
اليوم التاسع اي بعد مرور اكثر من
212 ساعه منذ حدوث الزلزال المدمر هذه
الصور كما قلنا سجلت قبل قليل لعمليه
هادئه لانقاذ المبشره صور الزلزال قدمت
صور صور متناقضه رجل يبلغ من عمر 77 عاما
تم انقاضه وكذلك طفل رضيع مازال في شهوره
الاولى ايضا صور من الحياه يقدمها هذا
الزلزال مره
بعد مره
[موسيقى]
ايضا من المناطق التي تضررت بشكل كبير في
جنوبه تركيا اذا ما اضفنا لها مركز
الزلزال في الكهرمان
ومناطق اخرى شاهدنا فيها صور مروعه لما
احدثه هذا الزلزال الذي وصفته منظمه الصحه
العالميه بانه الاعنف الذي عرفته اوروبا
خلال هذا القرن
[موسيقى]
هذا وقال الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
ان زلزالين غير المسبوقين اللذين يوم
الاثنين الماضي تسبب في مقتل ما يزيد عن
35,400 مواطن جاء ذلك في مؤتمر صحفي
للرئيس التركي عقب اجتماع الحكومه التركيه
في مركز اداره الكوارث والطوارئ في
العاصمه التركيه انقره
تاثير الزلزلين انتشر على مساحه تزيد عن
مساحه بعض الدول وشمل تاثيرهما المباشر 10
محافظات تركيا لقد انتج طاقه تعادل مئات
القنابل النوويه
زلزاله كهرمان مرعش تسبب في خسائر كبيره
في الارواح والاموال وفي ازاحه الاراضي
التركيه لمسافه ثلاثه امتار نحو الجنوب
اؤكد لكم ان الدوله لن تترك مواطنيها سواء
الناجين منهم او النازحين دون رعايه
فاليوم يوم الوحده والتساند والتعاضد
معنا من اسطنبول الحسين اوروج نائب مدير
هيئه الاغاثه الانسانيه التركيه اهلا بك
سيد حسين ما زالت الاخبار المفرحه
والحامله للالم الامل عفوا
لانقاذ اشخاص
بمختلف الاعمار بين ساعه واخرى وبالتالي
كيف تصفون هذه المرحله من مراحل البحث عن
ناجين وكذلك البحث وانتشال جثث منهم تحت
الانقاض
الخير
ما نزلوا نصل الى اخبار جيده
في رقنا للبحث والانقاذ نشطه وكذلك الفرق
الاجنبيه
وما نزالوا نصل الى اناس ما يزالون على
قيد الحياه
والناس يفرحون بذلك عندما يرون احدهم يخرج
حيا كان هناك ايضا امراه في الثانيه
وسبعين تم انقاذها ونحن ما يزال لدينا امل
اذا امكننا ان نصل بعد
2122 ساعه نامل ان نفعل ذلك وجميع الفرق
على الارض
تشعر بالحماس وبعد اليوم التاسع تعمل هذه
الفرق الفرق من اجل الوصول الى اكبر عدد
ممكن من الاحياء ما يزال هناك امل طيب
بالاشاره للناجين سيد حسين
كيف تصفون تكفلكم الان بالناجين فيما
يتعلق بتوفير الخيام للجميع توفير الاطعام
والدفء في ظل هذه الظروف الجويه القاسيه
الى اي مدى انتم متحكمون الان فيما يتعلق
بالتكفل بالناجين
نعم عندما يتم انقاذ احدهم هناك اخبار
جيده من المنطقه لكن جزء اخر هو المساعده
والدعم هناك ملايين
يوجدون خارج بيوتهم في جو شديد البروده
وما يحصل هو ان بعض هؤلاء الناس يتم نقلهم
الى مدن اخرى
وبعضهم يبقون هناك والحكومه التركيه
لديها معدات
وهناك قرى تتم اقامتها
ببعض الدفء
وفي كل مدينه ومقاطعه هناك مطابخ تقدم
الطعام
وليس ذلك
مقتصرا على تركيا يمتد الى سوريا ايضا
وهذه الجماعات
النشطه وتقدم الطعام
وننتج ايضا كميات كبيره من الخبز
ونتقاسمها مع الجميع نحاول ان نحقق
احتياجات الناس في تركيا في المدن وكذلك
في سوريا وهي مهم بالنسبه لجميع عملياتنا
سيد حسين من الصور القاسيه هناك عدد كبير
من الاطفال الذين فقدوا عوائلهم ونجوا هم
ما خطتكم لهؤلاء في هذه الايام
من بين الالف طفل الذين فقدوا اسرهم بعضهم
تحت مؤسسات حكوميه وبعضها مع اقاربهم
من تعرض اباؤهم
للاصابه فان جميع الفرق تعمل من اجل ان
تساعدها هؤلاء الاطفال
وتجد لهم اسرهم
والا
اذا لم يمكن فان الحكومه
الحكوميه تهتم بهم او اقاربهم
واليتامى ومن له عائلات هي مساله حساسه
جدا ولن نتخلى عنهم
والاسر والحكومه سوف تهتم بجميع الاطفال
الذين فقدوا عائلاتهم شكرا لك من اسطنبول
نائب مدير هيئه لغات الانسانيه التركيه
سيد حسين اوروج شكرا
معنا من عمل الدكتور محمود زريقات استشاري
الطب الشرعي والسموم دكتور محمود ابدى معك
بالاخبار المفرحه عندما نسمع بين فيله
واخرى عن التمكن من انقاذ من كان تحت
الانقاض سواء كان رجل بعمر 77 كما تابعنا
قبل لحظات او اطفال رضع في اليوم التاسع
كيف يستطيع في هذا العمر او في عمر غيره
ان يتمكن من البقاء على قيد الحياه ما
تفسير ذلك
مساء الخير اولا يعني حقيقه
فرص النجاح لكبار السن او للاطفال هي
تعتمد على عوامل او الانسان المحاصر بشكل
عام تعتمد على عوامل اهمها وصول مصدر
للمياه ومصدر او مرور الهواء لتنفس منه
اذا تواجدت هذه العاملين الرئيسيين يعني
مصدر للمياه والهواء وكان المكان المحاصر
فيه ليس ضيقا حتى يتمكن من التنفس
براحته
وتعرف انه عمليه التنافس يستهلك الاكسجين
ويفرز ماده ثاني اكسيد الكربون وتراكم هذه
الماده او ثاني اكسيد الكربون في منطقه
محصوره لا نفاد منها تؤدي الى الاقتناق في
فتره لكن فرص البقاء او على الحياه
لصغار السن للرضع هي معروفه
فرص اكثر من كبار السن او الشباب او اللي
بيكونوا اعمارهم وسط من الخمسين للستين
للسبعين سنه هذا
يعني من العوامل اللي بتساعده على البقاء
استهلاك كل الاكسجين اقل استهلاك الماء
اقل والظروف المحيطه الموجوده كمان هي
الحاله في الزلازل التي ضربت تركيا وسوريا
الشقيقه يعني البروده ساهمت في ان يقلل من
تعطش الاشخاص الموجودين تحت الانقاذ طبعا
احنا بنحكي انه الغذاء او الطعام هو عامل
ثانوي يعني يمكن للانسان ان يعيش فتره
طويله وفي عنا الدراسات حكت او العملية
وجدنا حتى بعد ثمانيه الى عشر اسابيع ناس
على قيد الحياه لكن بعدم وجود الماء وكلما
قلت الفرصه للوصول الى مصدر للماء او
للهواء معا فهناك فرص اقل للح يعني في امل
انه نلاقي
تحت
الخاتم عندما نتكلم عن زلزال بهذا الحجم
وهذا الاتساع ما هي اهم الصعوبات بالنسبه
للطبيب الجنائي عندما نتكلم عن عشرات
الالاف من الجثث
نعم
اليوم
الكل بيعرف انه تطورت يعني وسائل الكشف
على الجثث والتعرف عليهم من خلال مقارنه
باستخدام الصبغه الوراثيه اللي لكل شخص
والاشلاء لمن تعود يعني اليوم سهل جدا في
غياب وجود معالم جسم الانسان يعني التعرف
عليه من خلال الوجه اللي احنا يعني بنعتمد
عليه اكثر اشي لحتى المقارنه مع مع وضعه
لما كان على قيد الحياه لكن اليوم الديانه
بيساعدنا كثير والفرق متدربه والمختبرات
اليوم متطوره في في التعرف على الجثث
ويعني لمن تعود سواء ديانه هو اليوم يعني
عامل فاصل وتحليل ايجابي في مثل هذه
الكوارث هل تاخذ وقتا طويلا عندما اتكلم
عن كل هذه الاعداد المتوقعه
بالتاكيد يعني هناك احنا بنحكي عن عشرات
الالاف يعني من الجثث لكن ما تم انقاذه في
البدايه الامر يعني عوامل الرطوبه وعوامل
الهواء الرطب والبروده
ساهمت في بقاء معالم الجثث بدون تغيرات
التغيرات اللي بتصير بعد الوفاه تتاخر
بوجود عامل عوامل للظروف الجويه البارده
كما هو الحال الان لكن لو قارناها بالظروف
لو كانت في الصيف او في درجات حراره عاليه
فهذا ما يعيقنا في التعرف على الجثث او
التعرف على
وجوههم حتى نصل الى لمن تعود الجثث اليوم
في بدايه يعني كل ما زادت فرصه الانقاذ
اول يوم هي تعتبر فرصه قويه لمحاوله انقاذ
العدد الكافي من الناس كلما زادت الفتره
الزمنيه كلما قلت فرص النجاه لكن بخصوص
الجثث بشكل عام اليوم ليست هناك اي مشكله
بالرغم من العدد الكبير اعتقد الان ما تم
يعني انقاذه او ما تم انتشاله من من
الكارثه هو ما يمثل الاغلبيه والباقي يمكن
التعرف عليه بوسائل سهله هي ما عن طريق
مختبرات
الجينيه والدي ان ايه ان شاء الله طيب
العوده لعنصر التفاؤل احد ضيوفنا خلال هذه
التغطيه وهو من فرق الاغاثيه قال نحن في
وهو تركي في تجربه سابقه في زلزال هايتي
عثرنا على احياء بعد 14 يوما وهذا يدفعني
الى التساؤل الى اقصى مدى يمكن للانسان
يستمر فيه على قيد الحياه في حال توفر
لديك كما ذكرت الماء على سبيل المثال
يعني تحديدا في الدراسه اللي موجوده من من
الاشخاص التي تم انقاذها في زلزال هايتي
هناك امراه عاشت حوالي تقريبا عشره اسابيع
اللي بعرفه انا يعني في حالات استمرت
ببقاء على الحياه في الظروف لكن زي ما
ذكرت في البدايه يعني تعتمد على عوامل
كثيره في المكان المحاصر اولا ووجود مصدر
للمياه وتعتمد على البنيه بنيه الجسديه
للشخص المحاصر كلما كان مثلا الشخص لو كان
عندنا مصدر للمياه وكان الشخص عليه طبقه
دهنيه او
النسبه الدهنيه من جسم الانسان كبيره
فرص بقاءه لفتره اطول يمكن ان يعيش بدون
طعام ولكن بوجود المياه يمكن ان يعيش الى
عشره الى 12 اسبوع بدون اي يعني تغيرات
تؤدي الى فشل في الاجهزه الحيويه من داخل
جسم الانسان من عمان الدكتور محمود زريقات
استشاري اطباء الشرعي وسموم شكرا جزيلا لك
تعاني المستشفيات التركيه في المناطق
المنكوبه من زياده عدد المصابين مراسل
الجزيره المعتز بالله حسن يطلعنا على
الوضع من داخل احد مشافي مدينه كهرمان
مراش
ما في واحد من المشافي التابعه للدوله
انقطاع العام في هذا المشفى طبعا ما تراه
خلفي هو ليس كله من الناجين لان هذه
مستشفى وهذا قسم العاجل وبالتالي هناك عده
حالات هنا على الارض يمكن ان نلاحظ تقسيم
الخطوط وفق اولويه الحاله التي تاتي الى
هذا المكان وبالتالي سهوله نقلها عبر هذا
المكان الى المناطق الاخرى سواء كان ذلك
لاجراء الفحص بالاشعه او اي شيء اخر يمكن
من خلاله ان يتم
معالجه هذه الحاله وبعد تحقيق الاستقرار
فيها حاله المصاب يتم نقله الى مشافي اكبر
ربما سواء في مدينه انقره او في مدينه
اسطنبول القائمون على هذا المشفى اخبروني
انه اكثر من الفي حاله من المصابين في
كهرمان مراش جاءت الى هذا المشفى وتم
تحقيق التدخل الاولي بحيث يتم تحقيق
الاستقرار في الحاله ومن ثم نقلها الى في
اخرى هذه حاله اخرى قد تكون
لحادثه ما ليست ربما من النقاط لكن هي
فرصه لارى ماذا في الداخل كما تشاهد هناك
الكثير من الحالات موجوده في هذا المكان
هناك محاوله
لتحقيق الاستقرار في الحالات وايضا هناك
ضغط على هذه الاقسام في هذا المشفى وهذا
الحال هو الحال نفسه في كل المشافي الاخرى
في هذه المناطق اكثر من 2000 حاله كما
ذكرت واطباء اداره المشفى اخبرتني ان اكثر
من 90% من الاطباء في هذه المشفى تركوا
منذ بدايه الزلزال
عائلاتهم وجاوي لهذا المكان ليشاركوا وما
زالوا يشاركونا في اعمال الانقاذ ومحاوله
استقرار الحالات ايضا بحسب ما فهمت ان
الوضع الان في العاجل هو استقر نوعا ما
لانه لم يعد هناك الكثير ممن يخرجون من
تحت الالقاب
الجدل بشان دخول المساعدات الى مناطق
المعارضه السوريه في شمال الغربي سوريا
مستمر فبعد اعلان الامم المتحده موافقه
الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد استخدام معبرين
اضافيين قال الدفاع المدني في شمال سوريا
ان ذلك منح النظام مكاسب سياسيه مجانيه
على مرمى البصر يمتد الدمار الذي خلفه
الزلزال في شمال غربي سوريا حل دمار
الزلزال فوق دمار الحرب ليخلف وضعا يتفق
الجميع على انه كارثي لكن هذا الاجماع لا
يتحقق عندما يتعلق الامر بسبل مواجهته
انتظرت الامم المتحده سته ايام لارسال اول
قافله مساعدات وانتظرت بضعه ايام اخرى
ليصل وفد يمثلها الى المناطق المنكوبه
للاطلاع على الحاجات الانسانيه بعد
الزلزال اطلق الامين العام للامم المتحده
نداء لتمويل الاحتياجات الانسانيه
للمتضررين في سوريا الذين قدر عددهم بتسعه
ملايين
اعلن اطلاق الامم المتحده نداء لجمع ما
قيمته
397 مليون دولار من اجل تقديم مساعدات
انسانيه للمتضررين من الزلزال في سوريا
وسيغطي هذا فتره تمتد ثلاثه اشهر
لا يعرف هل سيثير تقسيم هذه المساعدات
جدلا كالذي تثيره المعابر الان فقبل هذا
الاعلان اعلن غوتيريش عن موافقه الرئيس
السوري بشار الاسد على مرور المساعدات عبر
المعابر مع تركيا واكد ذلك وكيله للشؤون
الانسانيه
نرسل المساعدات الى شمال غربي سوريا منذ
سنوات
اعطاء الاسد سلطه على مرور المساعدات عبر
المعابر مع تركيا واعلان سماحه باستخدام
معبرين اضافيين اغضبت الدفاع المدني
السوري في شمال سوريا قال مديره رائد صالح
ان ذلك منح النظام مكاسب سياسيه مجانيه
اما وحده تنسيق الدعم التابعه للائتلاف
الوطني السوري المعارض فقد دعت الامم
المتحده والمجتمع الدولي لتحمل مسؤولياتهم
واعتبار شمال غرب سوريا منطقه منكوبه اذا
يستمر الجدل بشان المعابر رغم حجم الكارثه
التي خلفها الزلزال فخلال الفتره الاخيره
سمح بدخول المساعدات من معبر باب الهوى
دون غيره لان الامم المتحده لم تمنح
تفويضا بذلك بسبب رفض روسيا بالخصوص التي
تعتبر استخدام هذه المعابر انتهاكا
للسياده السوريه
ورغم ان النظام اعلن من قبل انه سيسمح
بمرور المساعدات من مناطق سيطرته الى
مناطق المعارضه فان ذلك لم يحدث حتى الان
هذه قافله امميه اخرى تدخل من معبر باب
الهوى وتتالف من اثنتين وثلاثين شاحنه
تحمل مواد اغاثيه مختلفه وهذه اول قافله
تدخل من معبر باب السلامه الى شمال سوريا
بعد موافقه النظام لا يبدو ان ايقاع دخول
هذه المساعدات يتناسب مع حجم الاحتياجات
في شمال غربي سوريا فهناك يعيش نحو اربعه
ملايين ونصف مليون سوري اصبحوا كلهم
تقريبا في حاجه الى مساعدات لكن بالنسبه
لهم المساعدات الانسانيه لا تصل حسب
حاجتهم وانما وفق حسابات سياسيه لم تهتم
يوما بحجم الكوارث
معي منا حلب حمير عبد المغني ممثل صندوق
الامم المتحده للسكان في سوريا سيد حمير
هل من اجابات قد تزيل شيئا ما الاسئله
المطروحه الان مع مباشره دخول المساعدات
خاصه الى مناطق المعارضه السوريه فيما
يتعلق بوصول هذه المساعدات الى
مستحقيه والمخاوف لدى سكان شمال غرب سوريا
حقيقه الامم المتحده وصندوق الامم المتحده
لسكان في سوريا نتعاطى مع الموضوع من
الناحيه الانسانيه ولا نتعرض لك كثيرا من
النوعيه
هي ايصال المساعدات لكل
[موسيقى]
اينما كان بغض النظر عن انسيكات
والتنسيقات يتم
للاسف الصوت غير واضح تماما لذلك سنحاول
مره اخرى في حال ما كان هناك تحسن في
الارسال وفي الصوت
هذا وقال
المتحدث باسم الامين العام للامم المتحده
ان قوافل المنظمه الدوليه لم تواجه اي
مشاكل عند مرورها عبر معبر باب السلام
الحدودي لايصال المساعدات الانسانيه
للسوريين واكد دوجاريك ان الامم المتحده
تعمل على تقييم حاله معبر الراعي وانها
متفائله بشان استخدام المعبر بشكل سلس
وسريع
لم نواجه اي مشكلات في الواقع صارت الامور
على ما يرام هذا الصباح لدينا فريق تقييم
في الموقع الثالث معبر الراعي لمعرفه مدى
السرعه التي يمكننا من خلالها تشغيله
لكننا متفائلون جدا بان الامور ستتحرك
بسرعه كما قلنا تم استخدام الكثير من هذه
المعابر من قبل منظمات اغاثه غير تابعه
للامم المتحده والطرق المؤديه اليها في
حاله افضل من طريق معبر باب الهوى
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي قال ان هناك حاجه
الى فتح المزيد من المعابر على الحدود
السوريه التركيه واضاف انه لا عذر ابدا
لعدم المضي قدما في هذا الصدد اما
المندوبه الامريكيه بمجلس الامن ليندا
توماس غنفيلد فقد شددت على ضروره ان يراقب
المجلس تنفيذ اتفاق فتح معبرين اضافيين
لادخال الانسانيه الى سوريا
ان اي تقدم لايصال المساعدات الى الشعب
السوري يعد امرا ضروريا يجب علينا ضمان
عدم ايقاف المساعدات بقرار لمجلس الامن من
شانه ان يضمن ذلك ما نخطط القيام به حاليا
هو مراقبه تنفيذ الاتفاق بجديه اذا كانت
المساعده تتدفق بطريقه غير مقيده وحصل
الاشخاص على المساعده التي يحتاجونها
فسيكون ذلك جيدا
لكن علينا ان نراقب لنرى ما سيحدث استغرق
اتخاذ هذا القرار سبعه اياما للسماح بفتح
الحدود كان ينبغي اتخاذ هذا القرار في
اليوم الاول
من مقر الامم المتحده في نيويورك مراسله
الجزيره مراد هاشم مراد اذا
جلسه عاصفه الكثير من التشكيك الكثير من
الجدل وصل الى الدعوه الى ان يتم فتح
المعابر تحت البنده السابع لمجلس الامن
نعم عبد القادر وردا على هذه الانتقادات
الامم المتحده وتحديدا الامانه العامه
ترى انها لم تفعل شيئا جديدا اي انها لم
تمنح النظام السوري السياده او شرعيه
لانها اي المنظمات تعترف بهذا النظام او
ولديها مندوب لهذا النظام هو يمثل سوريا
ومن ان سعيها للحصول على موافقته
[موسيقى]
لاضافه معبرين اضافيه اضافيين كان هدفه
تسهيل وصول المساعدات الانسانيه دون قرار
من مجلس من مجلس الامن الدولي لانه دون
ذلك كان سيخوض سيؤول الامر الى المجلس
وبالتالي الى المعركه المعروفه حول اليه
ادخال المساعده الانسانيه ما يعني التاخير
وصول المساعده الانسانيه علما ان الامم
المتحده حينما اردت ادخال المساعدات
الانسانيه
دون اذن من النظام تطلب كما هو معروف
اعتماد هذه الاليه المستمره منذ 2014 وحتى
الان بدات باربعه منافذ انتهت الى منفذ
واحد باب الهوى الان بعد موافقه النظام تم
اضافه منفذين اضافيتين باب السلامه
والراعي
ليعمل الى جانب باب الهوى اليوم باب
السلامه استقبل اول شحنه اغاثه من الامم
المتحده اذ انه يستقبل شحنه غاته من
منظمات اخرى غير الامميه هذه الشحنه مكونه
من 11 شاحنه وهو باي وهذا المنفذ بذلك
يكون يستقبل اول شحنه عموميه منذ 2020 اذا
ان روسيا كما هو معروف اوقفت هذا المعبر
كما اوقفت معابر اخرى كانت عامله بسبب
معارضتها لهذه الاليه مجلس الامن يراقب
الان عمل المعبرين هناك فريق اخر في معبر
الراعي اممي بانتظار ان يشرف على شحنه
مساعدات امميه عبر هذا المعبر بطبيعه
الحال كانت هناك كان هناك حديث عنه لارب
24 ساعه من قبل الاعضاء مجلس الامن
لمراقبه ما سيجري في المعبرين الاضافيين
وانه اذا كانت هناك مشاكل فسيسار الى بحث
مشروع قرار تحت الفصل السابع من اجل
اعتماد اليه الزاميه
لادخال المساعدات عبر المعابر الاضافيه
هناك جلسه مشاورات مغلقه صباح الاربعاء
بالتوقيت المحلي لمدينه نيويورك وتحديدا
بعد جلسه اليمن ستبحث وستنظر في التقييم
الاولي لعمل هذه لعمل هذه المعابر الامين
العام للامم المتحده قال قبل قليل ان
المساعدات الى سوريا بعد الزلزال لم تصل
بالحجم والسرعه المطلوبين وانه ينبغي ان
لا تتاخر عمليات الدعم وكذلك وصول
المساعدات وهي وهو حذر من هذا انه سيكون
بطبيعه الحال امر من عمل الانسان كما قال
وليس بفعل كارثه عبد القادر شكرا لك مراد
هاشم من من نيويورك شكرا جزيلا لك
اذا دخل اليوم اول وفد امميه رفيع المستوى
الى مناطق شمال غربيه سوريا من معبر باب
الهواء الحدودي مع تركيا وما يعيد تسليط
الضوء على اليه عمل الامم المتحده
واستجابتها في هذه المنطقه خلال وقبل
زلزال كهرمان
كيف تصل المساعدات المقدمه من الامم
المتحده الى مستحقيها في شمال غرب سوريا
تعتمد المنظمه الدوليه ببرامجها المتنوعه
على منظمات سوريه تعمل على الارض وتكون
هذه المنظمات شريكا للامم المتحده بعد
استيفائها شروطا ومعايير معينه بدايه كيف
كانت اليه العمل في شمال سوريا بعد حدوث
زلزال كهرمان مراش تقول منظمات عامله على
الارض انها اسره بواسطه فرقها مسحا اوليا
لمنطقه واكثر ضربها الزلزال وذلك بالتعاون
مع جهات عامله هناك مجالس المحليه واداره
المخيمات وغيرها هذا المسح يرمي الى جمع
معلومات تتعلق بالاحتياجات العاجله مثل
اقامه مخيم جديد وتقديم مساعدات غذائيه
وطبيه وغير ذلك ثم تقدم قائمه الاحتياجات
هذه لهيئات الامم المتحده المعنيه
بالمساعدات المط
قبل الزلزال كانت كل منظمه شريكه مع الامم
المتحده لديها قائمه معلومات تتعلق بعدد
المشمولين بالمساعده من سكان المنطقه او
من بين النازحين وبعدد الاطفال والنساء
والمرضى وقائمه بالمواد والخدمات المطلوبه
مساعدات الامم المتحده تكون في مخازن
التابعه لها في مدينه الريحانيه التركيه
قرب الحدود مع سوريا تنطلق شاحنات سوريه
عبر معبر باب الهوى الى تلك المخازن لشحن
المساعدات ونقلها الى سوريا ويجري تسليمها
لكل منظمه شريكه للام المتحده كل حسب
مخصصاتها
[موسيقى]
من جنيف معنا شادي شحاده مدير التعاون
باتحاد منظمات الرعايه الطبيه والاغاثيه
في سوريا سيد شادي كيف وجدت هذه الخطوه من
قبل الامم المتحده فيما يتعلق بفتح هذه
المعابر ايصال المساعدات بل والدعوه من
قبل الامين العام المتحده السيد بجمع هذا
المبلغ من المال حوالي 400 مليون دولار
بشكل عاجل لتغطيه الشهور الثلاثه القادمه
هل هي كفيله باحداث تغيير انساني في
المناطق المتضرره
سيدي الكريم شكرا شكرا على الاستضافه شكرا
على التغطيه المستمره
لايام يعني مرت على منعناها كسنين بالنسبه
للمعابر سيدي الكريم القرار 2165 صادر على
مجلس الامن سمح بعبور المساعدات الامميه
من ثلاث دول هي تركيا والعراق والاردن اما
القراءه هذا في عام 2014 اما القرار
الاخير القرار 26 72 لم يسمح الا بعبور
المساعده الا من معبر واحد ولمده سته اشهر
فقط علينا الاعتراف بدايه سيدي الكريم ان
عبور القوافل الانسانيه ووصول المساعدات
الانسانيه هي حق وان وانا على ثقه ان اي
عامل بالشان الانساني يتفق معي بانه من
العار بان تكون قضيه وصول مساعدات انسانيه
موضع نقاش وخاصه عندما تتلخص قضيه شعب
وكانها قضيه ترخيص في المعابر والسماح
الانسانيه وايصال المساعدات سيدي ضرب
الزلزال يوم الاثنين فجر الاثنين من حوالي
8 ايام مضت ساعات يوم الاثنين والثلاثاء
والاربعاء ولم يصل شيء من اهم وهي هذه
الايام من اهم ايام الاستجابه من اهم
ساعات الاستجابه الانسانيه في يوم الخميس
اي بعض حوالي في اليوم الرابع دخل ست
شاحنات في يوم الجمعه دخل ربما 15 او 14
14 شاحنه يوم السبت دخلت 22 سنه كل ما دخل
الى اليوم لا يصل الى 100 شاحنه 100 شاحنه
انسانيه لتغطي حاجه
جغرافيا يقطنها 4.5 مليون بني ادم انسان
يعني التعداد السكاني يقارب تعداد سكان
دوله الكويت الشقيقه يقارب تعداد سكان
القوي الكويت القطر والبحرين المجتمعين
منهم اربع مليون بحاجه نعم ومساعده
انسانيه منهم ثلاثه ونصف مليون او اكثر
بحاجه دعم صحي طيب نحن نتكلم عن جغرافيا
تتعرض لكارثه خلف كارثه وراء كارثه بعد
كارثه من حرب وقصف وبراميل وقصف ما الذي
المجتمع الدولي في هذه الحاله تابعنا
اليوم جلسه مجلس الامن هناك مثلا فرنسا
حتى طلبت من يتم فتح المعابر تحت البند
السابع هناك انتقادات من قبل واشنطن ولكن
في المقابل روسيا تقول بان هذه المعابر
تدخل ضمن السياده سياده الدوله السوريه
وبالتالي حتى الامم المتحده لا تستطيع ان
تفرض مواقفها حيل هذا الوضع
سيدي يقال ان كلمه سوريا تعني السيده
السياده في تاريخنا لغه ما هي سوريا سوريا
هي السياده ولكن صدقا عندما يكون طفلي او
طفلتي تحت الركام السياده لا تعملي شيء
سياده كل الدولات عندما يكون طفلي تحت
الركام عندما تكون امي تحت الركام السياده
لا تعني لي شيء عندما يكون ورايناها على
شاشه الجزيره الطفل النائم في منتصف الليل
في درجه حراره تحت الصفر عندما يكون طفلي
جائع ويشعر البرد والمريض ولا يجد علاج ما
هي السياده في اول ايام الزلزال سيدي
الكريم في احد مشاكل التي ندعمها والتي
نسيرها والتي نسير عملها في شمال غرب
سوريا عدد الجرحى بالعشرات في مستشفى فيه
جهاز اشعه واحد
طابور الانتظار على جهاز الاشعه يتخلله
الموت
بين المرضى ولا يمكن للطبيب التدخل
الجراحي الا بعد الصوره الشعاعيه
سيد الحاجات اليوم في سوريا
قبل قبل الزلزال وصفت الازمه السوريه
بانها الاسوا منذ الحرب العالميه الثانيه
انا اخشى صدقا اخشى ان ما بعد الزلزال
التقارير والدراسات ستورد ان هذه الازمه
هي الاسوا منذ الازل منذ الازل نحن اليوم
بحاجه لموارد طاقه لتسيير المنشات الصحيه
نحن بحاجه الى مشتركات طبيه بحاجه الى
اجهزه وهذا المنظور طبي منظور عام نحن
بحاجه الى ماوى وعلاج وماء ماء للشرب صالح
للشرب وطعام ولكن اسمح لي بان اؤكد بان
اؤكد لان كل السوريين ما يحتاجون له اليوم
ومن اهم الاحتياجات هي وجود التزام مخلص
وطويل الامد بالدعم بهدف خلق البيئه
الصالحه للتنميه بهدف خلق قادر على اكتفاء
عبر مشاريع الدعم
انساني وتنموي مشتركه وطويله الاجل بخطط
استراتيجيه واضحه يكون السوري منخرط
وضمنها الذي لاحظناه بالايام الاخيره من
تضامن من تعاظم من تبرعات من من تغطيه في
الايام الاخيره حتى نخرج طفل من تحت
الركام
هذا التعاضد يجب ان يستمر لان هذا الطفل
الذي خرج هذا الشاب الذي خرج يحتاج الى
اسعاف اولي يحتاج الى عمل جراحي يحتاج الى
متابعه صحه نفسيه في ابعاد الخروج بعد
الخروج يعني بعد اسبوع وبعد اسبوعين وبعد
شهر وبعد شهرين يحتاج الى الذهاب الى
المدرسه الى تعليم يحتاج الى ماوى يحتاج
الى فرصه عمل ثم يصبح قادر على الانتاج
وخلق حركه عجله انتاجيه ما يحتاجه
السوريون هي اراده سياسيه حقيقيه صادقه
لانهاء الالم السوري والالتزام بالسياسه
تضامنيه انسانيه والتوقف والتوقف عن اللعب
بالالم السوري في سراديب السياسه ككرت قوه
وكرت سيطره
لتبادل الالعاب
من جنيف شادي شحاده مدير التعاون باتحاد
منظمات الرعايه الطبيه والاغاثيه في سوريا
قدرت الامم المتحده ان اكثر من سبعه
ملايين طفل تاثروا بالزلزال المدمر
والهزات الارتداديه التي اعقبته في كل من
تركيا وسوريا واعربت منظمه الامم المتحده
للطفوله يونيسيف عن مخاوف من ان يكون
الالاف من الاطفال قد لقوا حتفهم في
البلدين بفعل زلزال كهرمان مرش متواضعه
[موسيقى]
في الذات الكبد
من لا يتالم لضر يصيبها فكيف بفقدها
يخشى ان الاف الاطفال الاتراك والسوريين
قد قضوا في كارثه الزلزال الامم المتحده
التي تقول ذلك تتوقع ان الحصيله النهائيه
ستكون مرعبه لم يخلو المشهد من لحظات
تبتهج فيها الملايين وتبكي في ان معه
الحمد لله يحدث ان تخرج القلوب الصغيره
خفاقه من تحت الانقاض لكن سرعان من يواجه
معها حيره السؤال المحتوم عن اليوم التالي
تقدر عموم المتحده ان اكثر من سبعه ملايين
طفل تاثروا بالزلزال بكل من تركيا وسوريا
ففي المحافظات التركيه العشر المتضرره كان
يعيش ما مجموعه اربعه ملايين الف طفل
بينما تشير التقديرات الامميه الى تاثر
مليونين ونصف المليون طفل في سوريا
الاثر باق بالرغم من النجاه الموصوفه في
احيينا كثيره بالمعجزه
فطفوله هؤلاء تعبر الى محنه جديده تشكلها
الاصابه او الصدمه او فقد الاهل والماوى
او جميعها معها
تقول هذه السيده ان ابنائها باتوا يرددون
ان طفولتهم قد ضاعت
الحقيقه ان معظم الاطفال الناجين من كوارث
مماثله تهزهم في الغالب صدمات نفسيه او
اعراض ما بعد الصدمه
تلقي العلاج النفسي والدعم الفردي
والجماعي قد يكون متاحا للاطفال المتضررين
في تركيا اكثر مما هو بنسبه لاقرانهم في
سوريا وجه الاختلاف الاخر بين الحالتين
مرتبط بمصير الاطفال الذين كتبت لهم
النجاه ولم تكتب لذويهم
يؤكد نائب الرئيس التركي ان 574 طفلا
انتشلوا من انقاض مباني منهاره وجدوا بدون
اهاليهم ويضيف فؤاد اقطاعي ان 76 منهم فقط
اجتمعوا لاحقا بافراد من عائلاتهم مع ذلك
تبدو الحاله السوريه اشد سوءا فالى اين
يوجه يتامى الزلزال هناك من الاطفال
الى دور الايتام المكتظه في الاساس ام الى
بقيه اهل في بقعه ما من ارض سوريا
شتت الحرب كما نعلم شمل العائلات السوريه
خلال العقد الماضي مما يعقد الان عمليه
العثور على اقرباء للاطفال الناجين من
الزلزال
حتى الناجون مع اهلهم لا يخرجوا سريعا من
دائره المعاناه
فالماوي المؤقته لن تغني عن دفء البيت
المفقود
وتقبل العقول الصغيره وضعها الجديد سيحتاج
لبعض الوقت
حذر المدير الاقليمي لمنظمه الصحه
العالميه في اوروبا هانس كلوغي من التبعات
الصحيه لزلزال كهرمان مراشد وفي مقدمتها
انتشارا الاوبئه والامراض المعديه واكد
كلوجا وقوف المنظمه الى جانب السلطات
الصحيه التركيه في مواجهه تلك التحديات
بعد مرور اكثر من اسبوع على هذه الماساه
الرهيبه تزداد المخاوف بشان القضايا
الصحيه المرتبطه بالطقس البارد والنظافه
والصرف الصحي وانتشار الامراض المعديه
كلها تحدق بالاشخاص الاكثر عرضه للخطر
بشكل خاص اذا نقف الى جانب السلطات الصحيه
التركيه فقد ابلغونا بارسال امدادات
اللقاحات شديده الاهميه بما في ذلك
التطعيمات ضد الكزاز وداء الكلب الى منطقه
الزلزال وبمباشره الصيدليات المتنقله
عملها هناك
كما وصف كلوغي زلزال ضرب كلا من تركيا
وسوريا بانه اكبر كارثه طبيعيه منذ قرن
تضرب بلدا واقعا في منطقه الفرع الاوروبي
من منظمه الصحه العالميه والتي تضم تركيا
حان الوقت لكي يظهر المجتمع الدولي الكرم
نفسه الذي اطهرته تركيا لدول العالم على
مر السنين هذا البلد موطن لاكبر عدد من
اللاجئين في العالم لدينا اكثر من اربعه
ملايين شخص من سوريا المجاوره وقد فقد
الكثير منهم مجددا كل شيء اننا نشهد اسوا
كارثه طبيعيه في منطقه الفرع الاوروبي
لمنظمه الصحه العالميه منذ قرن
اذا قصص انسانيه وازمات نفسيه كثيره خلفها
زلزال تركيا طارت طالت حتى الناجين من هول
الكارثه جانب من هذه القصص نتابعه في
التقرير التالي
سيده تركيه نجت مع اطفالها الثلاثه من
الكارثه تبني لها حياه جديده في الشارع
اهمها الاول هو ان يتلقى اطفالها رعايه
واهتماما وبيئه حاضنه تجهلهم اكثر شجاعه
وقادرين على تحمل الصدمه
تعودنا مشاهده الزلازل والكوارث المماثله
على شاشه التلفزيون لم نتخيل ابدا اننا
سنمر بهذا يوما ما
لكل طفل قصه ومشهد صعب عاشوا تحت الانقاض
ليس من السهل محوه ولا تجاوزه الا بالدعم
النفسي المتخصص السيده تولاي تحاول تقديم
هذا الدعم لافراد اسرتها وقد اصبحوا على
قارعه الطريق
لقد دمر انفسهم يقولون لا نريد ان نعيش
هكذا اريد غرفتي اريد العابي اريد ان اعيش
في منزلي ننجح في ايجاد طريقه لتعزيتهم
قصه مؤثره اخرى في موقع مختلف في هاتاي
تقيم عائله نجم الدين دي ميرسي امام مبنى
منهار وقد وضعت صوره احد اطفالها
المفقودين على جذع شجره علها تجد من يتعرف
عليه
لم يعثر على اي اثر لاقارب حتى الان هناك
ثمانيه اشخاص بالداخل ولا توجد اخبار عنهم
على الاطلاق
هزه ارضيه امتدت ثواني معدوده وخلفت ماسيا
جما حتى للناجين وحياه تحولت في غمضه عين
الى ازمات نفسيه كبيره قد تلازم بعضهم
طوال حياتهم انهم اليوم معرضون لما يعرف
برهاب زلازل
قدم ملك بريطانيا تشارل الجزء الثالث عزيه
في ضحايا زلزال تركيا وسوريا خلال زيارات
لجاليتي البلدين في لندن وزار الملكه
تشارلز الثالث خيمه عزا لضحايا الزلزال
السوريين في ساحه الطرف الاغر وسط العاصمه
البريطانيه
نحن هنا في ساحه الطرف الاغر وسط العاصمه
البريطانيه لندن نرقب وصول الملك تشارلز
الثالث الى هذه الساحه التي اغلقت في
ساعات ظهيره هذا اليوم وصل ليقدم التعازي
في ضحايا زلزال تركيا وسوريا في هذه
الخيمه التي نصبت هنا في وسط ساحه الطرف
الاغر المغلق الان امام الجمهور خيمه نصبت
لمجموعه من الهيئات والمنظمات والجمعيات
السوريه السياسيه والاغاثيه التي ستستقبل
التعازي بضحايا الزلزال خلال الايام
القليله المقبله حتى يوم الجمعه المقبل
الملك تشارلز الثالث جاء من منطقه هونزلو
غربيه لندن حيث التقى
بمتطوعين يجمعون التبرعات والمساعدات
لضحايا الزلزال من الجاليه التركيه تحديدا
وقال لنا منظموه هذه الخيمه ان المكتب
مكتب قصر
تواصل مع هذه المنظمات السوريه وطلبوا
منهم عنوانا يتوجه اليه الملك لتقديم
التعازي للضحيه السوريين بهذا الزلزال
ويطلع على بعض التفاصيل كما ذكر لي
المنظمون بعض التفاصيل المتعلقه
بالناجين من الزلزال بعض الاقارب الذين
يعيشون هنا في المملكه المتحده اقارب
ضحايا الزلزال سيطلعون الملك على قصصهم
سيرغون له حكاياتهم
وسيتحدثون عن ما تحتاجه سوريا في هذه
الفتره العصيبه بعد ان الحق الزلزال الضرر
والدمار واوضح بحياه الالاف محمد المدهون
الجزيره لندن
في اخبار العالم الاخرى تابع تطورات
الازمه في تونس حيث دعا الرئيس التونسي
قيس سعيد من وصفهم بالقضاه الشرفاء الى
تحمل مسؤولياتهم التاريخيه حتى تستعيد
تونس عافيتها وفق قوله واضاف سعيد خلال
لقائه مع وزيره الخارجيه التونسيه ان
البلاد تخوض حرب تحرير ضد من وصفهم
بالمجرمين في حق الشعب مضيفا ان الايقافات
الاخيره اثبتت تورط عدد من الاشخاص في
الازمات المتصله بتوزيع السلعي الاساسيه
لقد اظهرت الايقافات الاخيره
ان عدد من هؤلاء المتورطين
المجرمين
المتورطين في التامر على امن الدوله
الداخليه والخارجي
وهذا بالاثباتات
عمر الذين يقفون وراءه هذه الازمات
المتصله
بتوزيع السلع
وبالترفيع في الاسعار
اعرب ان دوجاريك المتحدث باسم الامين
العام للامم المتحده عن قلق المنظمه ازاء
الاوضاع في تونس لما وصفه بتقلص المساحه
المتاحه للمعارضه وللمجتمع المدني وللصحفي
وقال دوجارك ان المنظمه ان يكون هناك مجال
للحوار بين جميع الاطراف في تونس
نتابع بقلق الوضع في تونس بما في ذلك تقلص
المساحه المتاحه للمعارضه وللمجتمع المدني
والصحفيين ما زلنا نامل ان يكون هناك مجال
للحوار لكننا نتابع الوضع عن كثب
عقد في مقر حلف النيتوبي بروكسل الاجتماع
مجموعه الاتصال الدفاعيه الاوكرانيه التي
تضم اربعا 54 دوله وقد تعهد حلفاء
اوكرانيا بتقديم المزيد من الاسلحه
والذخيره والدبابات وقال مسؤولون
الدفاعيون في الاجتماع ان الحرب مع روسيا
تقترب من مرحله حرجه وقال الامين العام
للحلف
ان تزويد الاوكرانيين بالاسلحه التي وعدوا
بها للحفاظ على قدرتهم على الدفاع عن
انفسهم يشكل اولويه لكنه اضاف ان النقاش
يجري بشان المقاتلات التي نفى كونها
الاكثر الحاحا
الذي لا موجز رياضي مع معز بولحيها
[موسيقى]
ارحب بكم في جوله رياضيه موجزه نستهلها من
دوري ابطال اوروبا لكره القدم بعد دقائق
قليله من الان تنتهي على مواجهه باريس سان
جيرمان الفرنسي لبايرن ميونخ الالمانيه
نتيجه لحد الان ليتقدم الفريق البافاري
بهدف
لصفر فيما اي سي ميلان الايطالي لازال
متقدما على توتنهام الانجليزي بذات
النتيجه اذن بهدف
لصفر المبارتان اقتربت ايضا من النهايه
يتقدم على توتنهام في ذهاب دور 16 لدوري
ابطال اوروبا بعد هدف سجل في الدقيقه
السابعه عبر الاسباني ابراهيم دياز حافظ
الفريق الايطالي على تقدم هذا الى ما قبل
نهايه المباراه اذا بقليل علما وان
الفريقان يلتقيان مجددا في الثامن من
الشهر المقبل في مباراه
الاياب في لندن
نبقى في دوري الابطال يستضيف بروسيا
دورتموند الالماني الاربعه تشيلسي
الانجليزي على ملعب سيجنال دونا بارك وذلك
في ذهاب دور 16 ايضا للمسابقه الاوروبيه
دورتموند بلغ ثمن نهائي بعد احتلاله
المركز الثاني في مجموعته السابعه خلف
مانشستر سيتي من فوزين وثلاثه تعادلات
مقابل الخساره في مباراه واحده وحقق
دورتموند الفوز في اخر خمس مباريات في
الدوري الالماني كما انه بلغ دور الثمانيه
في مسابقه كاس المانيا
تشيلسي من جانب بلغ دور 16 بعد تصدر
المجموعه الخامسه محققا اربعه انتصارات
وتعادل مقابل الخساره في مباراه واحده
يعاني فريق تشيلسي في الاونه الاخيره اذ
حقق الفريق الذي يدربه دراهم بوتر الفوز
في مواجهتين فقط في اخر 12 مباراه
المواجهه الثانيه لليله الاربعاء يلعب
كلوب بروج البلجيكي امام ضيفي بنفيكا
البرتغالي بروج بلغ هذا دور بعد ان احتل
المركز الثاني في مجموعاته الثانيه خلف
بورتول البرتغالي محققا 3 انتصارات
وتعادلين وخساره واحده في الدوري
البلجيكيه يمر بازمه في النتائج مما جعله
يتراجع للمركز الرابع وتعادل في سبعا من
اخر تسع مباريات وحقق الفوز مره فقط
وتعادل ايضا في مباراه واحده
فحقق مفاجاه دور المجموعات عندما تصدر
مجموعه الثامنه متفوقا على باريس سان
جيرمان الفرنسي بفارق الاهداف بعد ان حقق
اربعه انتصارات من بين الفوز على يوفنتوس
الايطاليه ذهابا وايابا في الدوري
البرتغالي يتصدر بن فيكان مسابقه متقدما
بخمس نقاط عن حامل اللقب وغريمه التقليدي
بورتو
بالعوده الى موقعه منذ اذا لحظات حسم
بايرن ميونخ الالماني مواجهه القمه امام
مستضيفي باريس سان جيرمان بهدف دون مقابل
في ابرز مباريات
ذهاب لدور 16
لمسابقه دوري ابطال اوروبا
حملت قمه باريس سان جيرمان الفرنسي وظيفه
بايرن ميونخ الالماني اهدافا انسانيه قبل
اهدافها التنافسيه فقد وقف الفريقان دقيقه
صمت حدادا على ضحايا زلزال تركيا وسوريا
الحذر بدا واضحا في النهائي المبكر وكانت
الفرصه الاولى لبايرن ميونخ بواسطه لاعبه
تشوبوتي
وفرصه هنا تاتي تصويبه لكن الى خارج
الملعب
كان موجود واشتمت رائحه الخطوره من راسيه
موتينغ التي مرت بجوار القائد
غياب كيليان مبابي الموجود على مقاعد
الاحتياط اثر بصوره واضحه على هجوم البي
اس جي الذي لم يشكل اي خطوره على مرمى
البافاريين في لقطه في فرصه لكن حارس
المرمى مرتاح وفي المقابل استمرت محاولات
البايرن ومنها تسديده يوشوا التي تصدى لها
ببراعه دوناروما
غابت المتعه والاثاره في الشوط الاول
لكنها حضرت مع مطلع الثاني فقد نجح كينج
سليكومان في افتتاح التسجيل لبايرن
بذكريات نهائي 2020 من المسابقه القاريه
كره منقوله من الطرف الايسر عرضيه ترسل
الخطوره التصويبه الله
التاخر في النتيجه دفع مدرب باريس سان
جيرمان للبحث عن حلول هجوميه تمثلت في
الدفع بمبابي لكن الخطوره استمرت بافاريه
وكان تشوبو قريبه من مضاعفه النتيجه لولا
الحارس دوناروما بمساعده من العارضه
وعودت دوناروم تالقه يتصدى لراسيه
[موسيقى]
وعندما يوجد مبابي فان الخطوره قادمه لا
محاله لكن رايه الحكم المساعد افسدت فرحه
التعادل وكرر امبابه محاولته لادراك
التعادل دون جدوى فانتهت القمه بفوز بايرن
في انتظار لقاء الاياب بعد اسبوعين
اذا مواجهه بهدف للسفر بذات النتيجه انتهت
ايضا مواجهه اي سي ميلان لضيفه توتنهام
سيكون ملعب الامارات مسرحا لقمه مرتقبه
تجمع ارسنال المتصدر بملاحق المباشر
مانشستر سيتي في مباراه المؤجله من
الاسبوع الثاني عشر من الدوري الانجليزي
الممتاز لكره القدم يحاول ارسنال تجاوز
نتائج في الاسبوعين الاخيرين فقد خسر امام
ايفرتون ثم تعادل امام برنتفورد يحتل
الفريق اللندني صداره المسابقه ب51 نقطه
مع مباراه مؤجله اذا ويتقدم بثلاث نقاط
امام مان سيتي الوصيف
انطلقت صباح الثلاثاء فعاليه النسخه
الثانيه عشره من اليوم الرياضي لدوله قطر
يقام هذا اليوم تقام فيه فعاليه رياضيه
ومسابقات مختلفه اذا شهدت حضورا مهما
للجميع هنا في قطر هكذا ناتي الى ختام هذه
الجوله الرياضيه الان الى ليلى